you just showed up like you might need
some practice uh you going down for the
count it's going down tonight I do it
all for my family you do it all for the
likes I hear that Bell and I'm ready to
fight Turn Me Up Turn Me Up Turn Me Up
they want the boat they don't work
enough don't mess around end up hurting
them I say the wrong thing make it
personal you say the wrong thing I might
hurt them all yeah what's up fam thick
boy Fam thank you guys for tuning in man
we got a very special Calabasas fight
campaign we got Jake Paul versus
Anderson Silva right now we're currently
watching Le'Veon Bell kind of given
Uriah Hall the business it's the third
round I expect this to go much different
shout out to Le'Veon Bell but let me
introduce the the crew here tonight we
got a special crew it's Halloween
weekend to my left we have one of the
funniest men in the business he should
have been canceled years ago he's a old
school 90s comic he's one of my favorite
people on the planet he gave me my
starting comedy at Sam Tripoli you are
welcome world you are welcome you're
welcome you're welcome
appreciate it man I love you send across
from me you guys saw me he's on the last
fight commands Jesse on fire one of the
best MMA Minds in the business he's on
YouTube he's on Instagram he's all over
and then directly across from me this
handsome bastard he should be the El
captain for the thick boy Fight Club it
is UFC Legend Hall of Famer Frank Mayer
good to see you guys man awesome happy
to be here with me yeah it's great dude
this is going to be interesting not UFC
sometimes times boxing build you know
not as entertaining you know but
um I love boxing yeah I love it but when
doing fight companions you know
sometimes boxing if this is a snooze
Fest that's a shot well the best shot
he's throwing the whole fight that I saw
he's been running backwards throwing
Jabs that right hand actually I think I
think heard him I'll tell you I'm
impressed with Le'Veon Bell man remember
he doesn't have a ton of fights at all
yeah yeah it's just the Adrian Peterson
Adrian Peterson looked real stiff yeah
real stuff but to go from that to you
know you're at home yeah I mean probably
has I don't know 15 years of combat
sport experience and this thing was
stand up yeah yeah and yeah I mean there
wasn't WKA kickboxing didn't he do the
uh Chuck Norris stuff yeah uh he did
some of that and then he you know his
grappling was never his thing because
wrestling his takedown defense was
ridiculous yeah and remember he knocked
out gay guard Musashi he knocked
Anderson sold out yeah Halloween night
uh two three years ago did you ever
train with him well you know he was
actually on the reality show I was uh
Jon Jones assistant coach I'm not doing
Fighter Ultimate Fighter sorry when he
did the uh against uh uh Chael sonen and
so he was on Jail's team and uh free man
I got to watch him I thought he killed
our guy oh yeah you know that Highway no
they don't remember Dana goes he's the
next Amsterdam silver yeah well you know
it looked like it it was hard to argue
with that but you know you can never
make those calls right I mean it's hard
to argue at that moment that he was
wrong no I agree Dan was uh right like
saying that I have no issue with that
what he didn't realize is that you know
I trained with Ryan for a long time at
rain he didn't realize that
um Uriah if his mind's right if he's
focused he was always the fight was
always in his head yeah because he was
so talented man like stupid talented but
you know sometimes when the lights are
on it's weird too it's the craziest
one time uh it was one of the first
times I think my wife would come into
the gym and Vito Belford was there
training with us right and there's Vitor
hitting pads right and he looks like a
freak uh his yeah Pat holder is like he
has a body shield on he's like knocking
him back at one point he holds a pad up
like about his head level and he jumps
40 inches off the ground throws a knee
you know these stories are free yeah
she's like who's that I had to feed the
Belfort oh my God right then like I
remember also being in the corner with
Vito one time we're in the same locker
room and he was getting ready to fight a
guy that used to try and spot a lot with
Marvin Eastman and he's just like hey
man like I was like oh you're about to
ask me about somebody I trained with and
that's kind of taboo issue yeah you
don't really do that you know what I
mean like we're in the locker room like
hey man you're fighting my friend that's
cool but I'm not going to disclose any
information I mean you know hey you know
you guys fight figured out yeah
well he walked up to me he's like hey
man
do you think I'm gonna win
literally put us a gash in his forehead
that looked like he got hit with an ax
that's one of the most historic freaking
you know yeah scars cuts of all time
that I mean I think it was about three
inches deep but then some of the guys
were coming and talking to me like oh
yeah that's Vitor it's just we got like
his head like it's the battle's in his
head yeah I mean like yep because if
that guy is on fire and all cylinders I
don't think anybody at his Peak stood in
front of him oh I'm tired I don't think
I saw your eye lose around in training
there you go yes Pat Cummings myself he
she we couldn't take him down literally
impossible to take down
he had him wobbled with an uppercut too
oh oh
I mean this is a this is a win for
Le'Veon 100 even with a decision yeah
for sure I keep legit earned the stripes
here oh big time that's impressive well
and you're I mean there's nothing off
your eye hole either honestly I love her
I love cyborg how's her only fans going
is she does she have only fans really
yeah she just started only fans good for
her I met her
[Laughter]
is that one of those like morbid
Curiosities I don't want to go look but
not Michael look yo now I gotta check it
out of people like dude this video is
awful don't look like I got let me just
don't say that to me you know like when
China was on the cover of Playboy that
was the highest selling Playboy ever
like China from China
yeah she died the first one that was the
highest sound too I don't think people
like new shoes like Jesus I didn't know
that she died I think it was Redondo
yeah yeah
if I remember correctly I think it was
like I think it was an opiates opiate
Edition yeah but like no one knew she
was dead for like two or three days like
if there's anything sad at the end of
your life oh yeah if I die and you don't
know for 72 hours and I'm dead that's
not good that's not good no no that's
like Dude things weren't going well yeah
you know a lot of good friends
oh someone's looking for me yeah I hope
at least mark would come check on me you
know like somebody yeah 72 hours two
hours or five minutes you're still dead
right I mean like it's like there's no
good but remember remember China is
worse ways yeah because I remember I was
watching this documentary on China it's
really good it's called China and uh
crazy I wonder how long they spitball
back oh I know so it's called it might
be one night in China but
um she she got out of the WWE she had
like an opiate addiction yeah she went
to Japan to wrestle and she was
wrestling like one of the top guys there
and you know he kind of even put it on
like oh I remember matches were tough
that guy fought like it was a fight yeah
like it was a fight fight and then he
was like you've earned my respect
tonight and all that and then she came
back to the States and for the reason
she had a fallen out with Vince McMahon
and then she had like this weird
boyfriend I think it was a guy broken
Pelosi's house gay Hammer sex yeah so
let's talk about that we'll get you back
dude you and Frank are me trouble
so then she couldn't do wrestling in
this in the states anymore because of
Vince McMahon and then started doing uh
porno in like movies I knew she did the
one because it was famous the One Night
in China yeah yeah yeah yeah
I can't believe it I haven't seen that
yeah I haven't seen that one yeah I'm
gonna love it because it was gonna watch
the porno talked about in the news but I
haven't seen the China you're gonna
watch the porno of course I'm gonna
watch it you've seen it I'm sure Sam I
have a joke about all the porn that I
watch on like PornHub is like from 2011
like I and it's like all the chicks I
beat off to are probably dead
dude like you talk you talked to a kid
who's like 24 now and they don't know
who Jenna Jameson is I'm like yeah no
Gemma Jamison's Charlie Chaplin to them
like it's just like yeah it is crazy
right yeah
back in my day our porn didn't have
sound yeah
you did great bro
yeah that China story is sad though man
yeah yeah then she and then she went to
rehab and then yeah then she got into
the opiates and just you know who knows
who knows
because when you have that kind of life
to like even go into any kind of normal
living let's say like you just didn't
want to wrestle anymore like what do you
do after that you can't go to UPS
she's doing like low budget movies but I
guess that didn't go well and then
that's when she started to do she had
this weird boyfriend started to do the
porno
it's frowned upon yeah
I mean those guys like I mean as
Fighters you know
training's rough but I could take days
off right you know and then like you
know you only fight I mean I think at
the peak of my career I was fight maybe
three times a year you know what I mean
so you get some time off you know it's
just a lot well you're like yeah we
champ then too yeah and leading up to
him before like so like you know 2008 to
2000 which is uh they don't do it now
yeah like how long would you do Camp
10 weeks you know what I mean because
typically I I made mistakes back then I
would get drastically out of shape in
between you know and basically you know
first four weeks was just me trying to
be able to survive a camp 30 weeks at
Camp though that's I mean that's a good
person here yeah and then as I got older
though actually I got smarter about it
and just like dude if I stay at 70 then
I could do a six weeks yeah yeah they're
not have the damage and so but anyways
but the pro wrestlers I feel the worst
for them because it's like you know they
what do they perform 300 times a year
yeah so I get it like you know like I'm
sorry I get up like yeah you know what
today we're gonna go ahead and just do
the aerodyne or we're gonna go do
elliptical they're like no you got to go
do a double handspring flip land on your
face and go take abuse for the next two
hours
and they're so they're crushing pills
all the time so like it makes sense like
I think unless you change their schedule
I don't see it and it's a tough go man
like you know down the road like you
said three times a year I used to know
one of the Champs and she was saying
that she had to like book her own travel
like she would fly like South choose
Champs Southwest booked her hotel she'd
be like the Madison in no no she's a WWE
Champion she was
pro wrestling money when you talk about
like the rock or stone cold but like
everybody else they don't make [ __ ] yeah
I have friends who are pro wrestlers and
I'll tell you I mean they're like oh
yeah I'm gonna do I'm like how much like
I'll be 1200 I'm like twelve hundred
dollars twelve hundred you're gonna show
up and go wrestle around and get hurt
and risk injury for 1200 bucks yeah and
you've been doing this for 20 years yeah
I'm gonna get that well I can sell my
merchandise that's their thing yeah
they're big on selling merchandise yeah
I'm like so then when you're done
wrestling you're gonna go out back and
have to actually like work and sign
autographs to really make your money no
like wrestling obviously compared to the
UFC it's not a sport but like the grime
oh yeah it's physically but that's why
there's a lot of opiate abuse yeah the
wrestler was that yes yeah yeah
it's the same business I don't know
I'm gonna die I'm gonna die yeah
it's so sad you're like just [ __ ]
well we talked about that that's why I
think you get so much hatred sometimes
yeah you know because I think there's a
lot of Hardcore you know guys that have
grinded out you definitely haven't taken
the normal path no yeah I mean but then
instead of being happy for you like yeah
I don't get people like there's only
there's only the whole notion is that
like there's only so much out there so
if one guy gets it that's that means
less for you that's really not true in
that business no it's not not that's
what they think though it's also not the
90s yeah there's not three ages it's not
specials yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so let
me ask you I I hope the UFC would open
up a pride wing of the Hall of Fame
because I feel like those guys never get
any discussion when you talk really talk
about the greats because when you talk
about the grace of all time A lot of
people are just you know they're going
like Jon Jones GSP khabib because
everybody's like today you know yeah and
then you know usually yeah yeah but
you're right I mean like look in the
2000s I mean like yeah I mean they
dominate Fedor uh Mirko you know no
Guerra I think during that time they
were yeah it would be interesting
bandoly Silva never get they didn't even
fight winning shoes
that's what they said you beat me to the
Shogun 19 dude ninja ninja and Shogun
yeah nuts the thing is Edelman like yeah
Mark Coleman yeah a lot of those guys
came to UFC that's why like the only
real
exactly yeah but like Fedor had his time
and pride and but he never came to UFC
all the other guys kind of came to USC I
mean Rampage was champion no one really
who was at the top of their game at
Pride came in and Dan at the top of
their game he said yeah Dan Henderson
Henderson Quinn probably did the best
yeah
when Clinton came over I mean look he
knocked out Chuck when Chuck was like
still Iron Man at that point Chuck was
on a seven or eight fight winner yeah
and then you know he held the belt for a
couple fights you know yeah he had that
thing where he he had some car thing
like there was he got in some car like
yeah like some monsters after we lost
the fight uh when he lost the title he
lost it to uh Force Griffin and uh he
stayed up real late you know and then he
really honestly like somehow I think he
got in his head that his friend needed
his help or something and Quinn like
like a hangout Quinn like you know I
love him the dude is like very much
about his brothers you know I mean like
if you're in his service like if you say
hey call someone up to bury a body at
two in the morning he's the dude I mean
honestly swear to God and duly noted
yeah I mean I'm gonna tweet it out but
yeah yeah yeah yeah but but that's into
it out with a monster sponsorship
so he had it in his head that his friend
needed him and so he jumped in the truck
and was like running cars over and [ __ ]
and just like had a little like had like
a mental breakdown I guess to say it
well Clinton's one of my favorite people
in the business he's great but on on
here like I mean he's great I just show
on his bike TV tonight 100 Clinton's
amazing you had to fight him I had to
fight him on the my Spike TV show what
was the show it's called wild world of
spike it was me Jason Ellis and kit cope
and then I remember that yeah decided to
put me in with Quentin Tarantino I
remember staring at him going wait
Clinton Rampage with Quentin Tarantino
no quick quick
I was like hopefully you beat up yeah
yeah yeah that's slightly Fair that's
like more fair fight yeah but uh it was
crazy because he's really nice to me and
then he would cork one off just to let
me know like rate my ribs like boom I'm
like oh [ __ ] okay no no he's a
physically strong guy oh dude his head
is enormous
yeah and he said I think he threw it he
tried to put him in a guillotine and he
goes he literally just stood up with him
he goes you know and herb is a 220 pound
guy he goes he didn't even it wasn't no
effort for him to extend his hips you
think about it I mean that dude picked
up in power bombed I mean yeah some yeah
I mean maybe I'd be the best knockout of
all time yeah
you ever see that where they're doing
the sports science they're talking about
like you know different strikes like
what generates the most energy and they
said that picking a human being up and
basically dropping him is like 400 G's
or some crazy number they're like
basically thank God you're on a mat
because if you've done that [ __ ] in the
street it'd kill you like basically
you're like almost like a 20. now
everyone learned like if everyone hooks
that leg
I got this one for people I'm like let
the [ __ ] go
this is a concept bro there's awesome
is a collectible guy look at that dude
he's got action figures a lot of toys
you know what okay I'm gonna see if you
guys when I see Anderson for some reason
like I feel like Mickey Mouse
yeah there's like a yeah there's like a
Mickey Mouse
in the world but he's so nice he's
cartoonishly nice yeah he's so nice
again I you know I was saying this when
they're asking me my predictions you
know every fiber in my body is a UFC
alumni it's Anderson Silverman yeah I
love Anderson but it's also a 46 year
old Anderson against Jake Paul like the
the world shouldn't work like this I I
do think it's me it could be a tough
night for Anniston yeah just being like
is Jake's so much younger quicker I
think Anderson's gonna outskill him
early on like the first three rounds
will be a little dicey Jake's I'm like
geez I can't land on this guy but
eventually his speed and quickness and
youth is gonna land something it's gonna
be tougher how many rounds is this I
think if Anderson takes it seriously and
doesn't play with him I think that he
wins I think if Anderson like even like
what he did with Tito where he like sat
against the corner lets Tito throw and
he's got his shirt and then boom hits
him with the right and a hook and steps
off it's like if you don't do that
because that [ __ ] if you does that with
Jake Paul could be a bad Knight I agree
but if he goes out there and takes him
seriously like all right look don't play
with this dude get him out of there like
hurt him quickly badly and for all eight
rounds until he can't stand up I think
he does what yeah if Anderson yeah if he
if he takes it serious and doesn't view
him as like a Disney YouTuber yeah if
it's Anderson dude
and then all of a sudden having his way
with him and then let me make a game of
this let me go ahead and draw this out
and have some fun if he starts doing
that I'm getting scared I agree Frank it
could be if Jake doesn't catch him with
a big shot and knock him out
he's gonna have a hard time Anderson's
defense is ridiculous yeah yeah and Jake
Paul so far and the fights that I've
seen so far he's done with Tyrone and uh
he's moving backwards right he's moving
backwards he's trying to you know and
he's throwing shots his Knockouts a lot
of times is their momentum right
Anderson doesn't move forward yeah I
mean like he does it once with Tim so
now he's gonna have to move forward on
somebody you know it's different you
know what I mean like the shot he hit
Woodley with Woodley was standing right
in front of him Woodley thought he was
throwing a body shot and he just got hit
with an overhand yeah
hunting them down yeah in that in the
two fights he moved backwards yeah
BJ back you know in 2008 2007 and stuff
uh I was actually
uh I don't know they'll get pissed I say
this but unless I see Rockman came in
the gym to train and I actually had to
watch BJ was sparring with me you know
BJ's you know uh was it was 200 pound
guy yeah and BJ Florida
B.J Flores Florissant Rock wow yeah and
not send again sorry the gym now uh uh
striking unlimited I make me I was there
I watched and they ran around the ring
and made sure everybody had their phones
had to delete it like delete that right
yeah right the rockman's corner and BJ
too he was respect he's telling his guys
so probably now I'm the dick because
it's only been like I was there I
watched I was like you know when Rockman
still look like rock me I mean thick
hair I mean he probably was and to
rockman's defense I think he was just
getting into Camp yeah and was like oh
okay I'll go ahead and spoil that
happened I outweighed by 60 pounds you
know what I mean did you ever uh spot
with Anderson did you ever come through
Vegas no just because the whole nagara
thing early on like oh that makes sense
yeah
I think Anderson don't like me oh
Anderson yeah because you know they get
like they they take it really personal
yeah yeah dude you shattered
that I get that but still like I don't
understand man I sent them but I mean I
hung out with guys that I beat and I've
hung out with guys have beaten me and I
mean like it's like dude right you know
it's like it'd be like being pissed at
your training partner we go and roll and
you give it to me right it's like I
can't talk to you for a week it's like
dude like yeah but don't talk to me
forever if you shatter my [ __ ]
shoulder and my things or just I bet you
yeah it's probably cool though yeah I've
actually hung out here to Tim like
within the like when the year of
actually uh a breaking his arm yeah yeah
he tried to pretend that his arm wasn't
broken and every person on Earth was
like no honest to God that's a tough and
he knew his arm was broken of course and
he'll tell you and he told me this day
he goes I just wanted to restart it
because I knew I had about 15 seconds to
knock you out so I was gonna come after
you on my left hand I was like wow
that's impressive because I was gonna
throw a head kick and see what happens I
just wanted to see this [ __ ] got really
bad I mean I hear you but the good thing
yeah we know it was messed up so I was
gonna check it out let's see how you
like it for check this with a forearm so
uh Frank I did the fight night flashback
rule went over his biggest fights like
you know like the Tim Sylvia one the
nugira the Brock Lesnar knee bar it's my
favorite fight of all time but um with
the Tim Sylvia one when you watch a
vintage Tim Sylvia
down the road hopefully people
acknowledge acknowledge this you're
talking about one of the best to ever do
it with his size speed and athleticism
you're talking six seven six eight
impossible to take down ridiculous uh
boxing were you saying you thought he
would kill it today if he was around
yeah I think you'd give Francis or
serial God issues he's just hit me a
mile away because remember he he could
box dude so hey he had that nasty right
hand he could jab like and he knocked
out the guys today don't use the reach
Andre when Andre at his top two you know
I mean like they had some great boxes
tonight oh did he they're keeping these
young lions and finally caught up with
me last night dude the one I texted you
guys about Haws dude he got caught in a
knee bar his knee popped what's his name
uh friend let him I think his friend let
him him go because he knew he popped his
knee and Haas I think he was in shock
dude like so he like ended up against
the fence and like nothing happened so
the ref was like I guess keep going
fight goes for another like minute and
then friend absolutely starched him like
it was one of the things it's a gnarly
finish we were traveling and I think I'm
gonna catch it later oh this is gonna be
a good fight these two chicks
what's going on with the one girl's
stomach she's still hot as [ __ ] but
there's some that's a baby mama yeah are
you sure yeah
the stretch but that it's there yeah but
there's not wrong she's so hot I don't
know I understand though they're like
you're gonna be you know you're just
playing surprise now hey I love the
baby's mama no it's cool but also
covered up all right so it's tough man
where is this fight by the way Arizona
see the giant Arizona flag oh yeah there
you go how how did this fight end up
higher on the build in Uriah and uh
that is interesting because even when
they promoted it and like the way I
promote it for for this uh fight
campaign was Main Event co-main Event
yeah because show time who I you know I
still talked to I was like Hey when when
does
um Uriah and uh Le'Veon Bell walked out
and like we're trying to figure it out
and like this coming event like yep
definitely coming event yeah I don't but
I'm thinking maybe they did that because
that was a four round fight that throws
me quicker and then oh that's Jake and
Amsterdam more time you know that's true
yeah having a four-round co-main is kind
of weird that'd be tough yeah for the
main event
remember when they told you that
hairspray caused a hole in the ozone
that was fine I do remember that
Sam can we that guy looks healthy dude
can we bring that up too dude can we
talk about this Nancy bro
when I looked into that guy yeah Frank's
on the team yeah dude we're in the safe
zone right yeah
now it's live it's okay dicey but circle
trust in this environment yeah that you
know what's going on Nancy well I know
her husband got beat up by a guy with a
hammer the only joke I made so far
because it's funny because Galen really
covers my gay is the right word Galen
comes my Twitter right because because
in my brain I go you know what would be
funny be like hey so are they going to
take away our hammers you know what I
mean like now I'm gonna have to wait for
the three-day waiting period to get my
hammer yeah you know like you know you
know yeah it's usually like when I text
him that he's all you
it was a Lover's Coral it was a lover's
quarrel dog no yeah dude
wait wait wait where did I pulled that
from no what wait wait it's pulling the
guy the guy says it the the if you look
at the picture of the glass the glass is
all coming out meaning that and also
security and this is again this isn't
coming so is Nancy a beard this yeah so
Nancy's in DC yes but but also this this
remember Nancy Pelosi's probably I mean
she's more powerful than Biden if you
think about it yeah so you know she's
third in line to get the presidency of
what happened so she's in DC when she's
in DC because you know she is hated she
has more security than anybody you know
even when she's gone so you're telling
me this guy who is making bracelets out
of a van next to somebody's house
broke in through the the White House
security no way but now it's coming out
that no the husband was like no he's my
friend let him in love with coral right
they're trying to over drug they're
trying to figure out who's going to suck
who is that someone this just gets
better this is oh [ __ ] but hunt it even
goes deeper than this and I'm sure you
know this the husband what three weeks
ago gets a DUI yeah wreck no that was
actually a long time ago he's a few
months ago yeah yeah he just got like uh
they just came up like they let him off
yeah exactly the trial or whatever yeah
here's what's interesting about that and
this which adds more value he was like
leaving a party with drinking or
something yeah but he was in uh I forget
a car he was in a Porsche both airbags
went off the only way an airbag goes off
is if someone's embodies over whatever
certain weight goes off and I thought
the controversies because I've heard
they even know that yeah he's like run
he's all run I guess well because you
know yeah because that's my whole thing
about all this dude it's like
the they just know what you're into they
find out what you're into and they see
if you can control you through some [ __ ]
dude they everybody has a dark story
but I think you're the one in control
if you're not hiding like the fact that
he's that blade like traveling around if
that's the case that means you know you
got nothing to worry about you're the
you're the alpha you're the Predator you
know what I mean like yeah you know what
I mean like you know the rest of us got
to hide our [ __ ] because I don't have
any power control right well what do you
think about Nancy and her husband's you
know he's blatantly being about this
doctor it's so obvious yeah but yeah
that's all crazy but they're like it
shows like 30 of all the stuff bro she
she had some more success she's the
greatest Trader of all time I mean they
just showed I mean so that's what I
thought about doing you know what I'm
gonna do they have those websites where
it just shows you what they do it's like
I'm just gonna follow their trades
because they know what the hell's up
inside a train sheets ahead of it so by
the time you get around to it everybody
else is trying well she's just doing it
based on on what they like she's on a
committee they're like oh we're gonna
green light this funding to go to blah
blah blah and then she tells him and he
realizing and which I mean Martha
Stewart did like what a year for that I
mean like how is that not all she did
she sold she got out of a stock though
she sold it would be bad to make 300
Grand or something like that yeah like
they make all the money on that yeah
when you're able to make the rules right
and you know what rules coming up yeah I
mean basically what we learned from this
is don't ask the dude who could beat you
up to suck your dick that's really
especially as a hammer right especially
close with a hand I mean dude or maybe
he told him not to suck his dick and
that's why he got beat up yeah
the cops don't deny the hammer let's use
dude you're 80 you're doing like high
you're doing like party drug gay sex at
80 no but here's my thing dude you're
doing it dude
you're 80. your wife is Nancy Pelosi and
you're messing around that Homeless dude
yeah have a little respect for yourself
dude get a little tweet that's right
it's got to be here in her chat right
now Nancy got some hitters you're gonna
do some fat cans yeah it's Gotta Be
shiny he's got to be paying for it so he
knows you get a young twink hairless
like a seal and he's he's on the [ __ ]
bill you know and you're just paying him
months dude you guys love homeless dudes
it's like its own genre do you ever
watch The First 48 boom
yeah White House hitter dude she's like
80 those tits are like 30.
yeah
speaker of the blouse
speakers
do you ever watch them do you remember
the shoes
so many of those stories there's like
some gay dude yeah some homeless guy to
crashes oh you need a place to crash in
my house and then it got weird and the
homeless guy went nuts remember the
homeless guy that Jimmy Kimmel like
there was a story about a homeless guy
who like saved a woman like from some
weird attack he like saved her and like
they made her and made him to a big
story Jimmy Kimmel had him on his show
okay well like a month later this story
happens like some rich gay guys letting
crash his house tried to do some gay
[ __ ] and the dude went nuts and I think
often why'd he go nuts though I thought
he was into gay stuff yeah well no I
don't think he won oh God it was just
like oh he got he got trapped into this
no no no no they're attractive the guy
asked the homeless dude to crash his
house and then tried some gay [ __ ]
wasn't down
the one singer uh George Michael he
would do that like wouldn't you like go
on cruise like like
yeah right in the park I think he got
caught with like a homeless guy right
like inside yeah so Robert Downey Jr did
Yeah Eddie Murphy
no rgj too oh yeah Iron Man oh yeah Iron
Man really he got pirate dude I don't
know if he got Papa dude he got popped
sleeping I might have made that up chin
bring that up but I am confused I know
Eddie Eddie Eddie Murphy Eddie Murphy
was with the trash can give someone a
ride I'm like dude
yeah
uh at two in the morning
yeah you're partner yeah I'm gonna do a
cooking show Robert Downey Jr caught
with see what would you say for uh
internet to Google it Robert Downey Jr
caught with hooker I feel like I would
have known him because you say caught a
bunch of drugs I mean dude yeah
are mistaking him for that movie did
below zero or something like that well
I'm seeing a Dallas Buyers Club I mean
dude he got popped doing blow a thousand
times yeah
yeah his was
uh I remember once a turnaround success
story though absolutely you go from
being like this I think they said like
his his agent like literally had like a
[ __ ] net trying to [ __ ] catch his
[ __ ] ass like running through like a
cartoon yeah yeah that's what I'm like I
was I'm like am I really reading this uh
go back to that chin what what was it he
did time driving naked yes right yeah
type in uh have you ever seen pictures
talk to the judge about it and he was he
gave this speech and I was like oh this
is a good performance he's all it's like
I have a gun in my mouth and I can't
stop I was like what were you gonna say
sam do you think a guy crashed his truck
and then like just kicks open the door
and he's Buck Naked yeah and he gets out
he starts walking like the Terminator
he's so mad he was obviously doing
something in there yeah oh yeah yeah
that's not a sober move no no no no dude
Robert Downey Jr just to uh be very
clear his things was just drugs he had a
gun in the car he like to do drugs and
he like would just crash it in like
somebody's house
they just found him in the next one so
Robert Downey Jr was arrested after
driving naked in his Porsche what kind
of Porsche did they just cut off with
cocaine heroin and a gun and they came
for him for that gun
and now now I'm almost bring this up
chin Warren Sapp got caught with the
transgender in Arizona during the Super
Bowl do you guys remember that no no
pretty sure I felt like I was all up and
I hate when people get caught up but it
is what it is
oh man he lost dude that blew up his
career huh no he was fine it says NFL
Network fired him dude you know what's
the craziest thing right now I was just
going through like broadcasting I'm like
what have happened to Warren Sap I swear
to God that I was thinking that today
just like running you know these random
thoughts you're just like oh you know
whatever happened to Warren Sapp you
know because we were talking about Tom
Brady like you know like oh that guy's
gonna be in broadcast yeah no problem
but he's not deciding the deal yeah
right well he had one already right
before he didn't yeah I'm pretty sure
cop says two oh two women you don't mind
you know what it's my own transgender
yeah I don't know what's happened bro
whenever I want a projection
well no they do like a beauty pageant
where it's all transgender it's tough to
tell bro like they're all I'm like wow
like okay that's scary right am I right
right I don't like the way I'm feeling
right now I know an uncomfortable
sensation yeah no Brian count has that
the best story he was entitling because
shooting hangover too where they filmed
in Thailand and he goes I'm telling you
dude these ladyboys you can't tell he's
like and I'm at a bar and he's like and
it's dark and he goes and then he's like
this girl is gorgeous dude she was into
me he's like damn yo so we go in this
they have like rooms there he's like
women's room we're making out cause I'm
just making out and I go down to you
know mess around and he knows I should
get a handful of dick and I go oh my God
you run out of yours no I don't want to
hurt his hurt her feelings I just kept
going I was like oh that's what you want
to tell yourself
hooked up with her
he's like I forget what happened and
then he just stares off he's off
I was like oh he is in the theater
that's an empathetic Soul right there
he's like I don't want to hurt yeah I
don't hurt his feet are you gonna pass
until you know and then once you know
it's like what you do it's on you my man
yeah yeah it sounds like Brian's gay
yeah that's why they did these fights
because you know three rounds you got
real boxers yeah they can kind of these
are like dictate good Fighters yeah
again uh Chris alvia yeah he's a badass
Le'Veon Bell got a decision for only
four rounds if it was long I think
Le'Veon Bell had been knocked out
that's kind of that's tough on for your
your eye haul and I doubt your house can
keep doing this like the lady on
battlefight was a one-off I doubt he's
just gonna keep boxing you know these
guys I wonder what he got paid for this
fight I mean four rounds he doesn't even
have to train for that really he
shouldn't yeah I mean unless you know
he's just putting balls deep in
kickboxing like you know is he going
back to kickboxing I don't think I think
he's done because he's basically tired
he got this opportunity uh but he talked
about how he's done he you know he
talked about very openly and shout out
to him about suicidal and like all that
[ __ ] so yeah yeah
yeah
oh yeah you'll like this
look at this Central Casting crowd in
the back
you you like this Sam I went on stage uh
last night in Calgary you know let's
talk about Newsom little boo that's fine
your prime minister how long you guys
want to pretend his dad's not wasn't
this really Romero Philadelphia and
what'd they say oh they go crazy nuts
yeah and I went I said that's what I
thought I'll wait for them is Rodriguez
and Sylvia but I mean the whole night
okay I was honest yeah I don't see it
either
Calgary I'll be in the back domain
greets I want to hear your argument that
his dad's not Fidel Castro oh dude his
dad's right after the show his dad's
Fidel Castro for sure
100 100 have you seen the pictures but
then also the mom and dad all hung out
with those pictures of him hanging out
well you know when the when the dad for
sure well they were they were swingers
yeah you know when the dad made the mom
she was I think 19 when they met or 18
she's my dude 16. dicey and then you got
made at 22 and then they would they were
fans for Del Castro they would vacate
Nation out there so somebody found out
the records when they went on their
honeymoon and they would go she would
have to be there in February or whatever
1971 so they mapped out they have it on
record all their travel but when they
went to the Caribbean where Fidel Castro
was it says on known Island it's the
exact time the exact time of the nine
months when she would have got pregnant
look at look at Trudeau's like Canadian
father and then look at Cash He looks
identical she can't decide to spy at the
same age and it's like dude in 2016 he
was like he was like giving Fidel Castro
props like you know well he's still
there it's his dad yeah well during this
whole uh pandemic he was complimenting
China yeah you know what China does
things very well you know the fact that
they were able to I'm like because
they're able to tell everybody to stay
inside their house with no reason
because you're gonna get shot okay like
I think I mean look at that you hear the
new thing today that the FBI doesn't
want to release the uh Seth Rich uh
information do you see that who's Seth
really Seth rich is the one yeah we're
back we're back is why Sam's here baby
he might have released the uh Hillary
Clinton emails to WikiLeaks maybe and
then got murdered yeah straight up oh I
wonder who did it yeah 100
now like we don't want to release it for
66 years what's up with them with this
[ __ ] with the dude 75 years
like all right no one's gonna go to jail
now yeah we're all dead but you'd also
lose all faith in government they
released all that stuff like the JFK
like back then there was a huge huge
Riot so everyone knows the inside job
but we don't now we're like oh we're
discovering it now no back then they
knew it yeah they release it to all the
people who would like you know
radicalize and actually do something
they're too old you know dude it's crazy
but I think about that though like if
the CIA really did it like oh I don't
know if it's cool
JFK for sure if yeah it's 100 sure yeah
but I'm saying everybody
dude almost everybody there they had
teams of assets don't say a lot of
Assassins a lot like how many were
talking he was like John Wick bro he
just walked in and you remember when all
the phones yeah and everyone's got a
phone in the plaza that's how it was and
the ones that were were basically off
later on you want to hear a crazy story
so we were just down there about two
years ago when Bella was wrestling
Dallas and Dallas and so we went on the
tour so one of the guys was our bus
driver goes you really want to know what
happened I was like all right so let me
hear your story so his version of it is
that they're all partying the night
before and the whole his all secret
service are all they're all drunk and
they're the only ones that have the M16
at that point because they're one of the
first ones to actually purchase them and
they bought like 60 of them whatever it
was like you know 1961 or whatever it
was 62 right so the M16 was brand new
and they were the first ones to actually
have them was their secret service guys
so that's why you can see actually a
picture of one of the guys sitting on
the back of his vehicle with one of
those weapons also reason why they were
so adamant about getting the bullet that
was actually in his head because I was
able to kill them so they're saying that
Oswalt was the real thing he doesn't
know if they were trying to kill him or
not but that guy really was up there and
he took a shot first shot hit went
through and because they were all
partying they were all kind of drunk the
one guy the driver floors it well one of
the bodyguards in the back this kid is
also basically not supposed to be there
but they're like hey man we're all kind
of hung over you just get on the back
and he's also the guy that goes and gets
the girls for JFK so he's like the you
know the procurer of the hookers get the
Wrangler right so that's the kid sitting
on the back car speeds off he falls
backwards fires a shot off hits JFK in
the back of the head he's the one that
actually killed him purely a screw-up
then the guy you know uh um Lee Harvey
Oswald gets a second his second shot off
that's why they say here three he only
fired two the first and the third the
second shot is actually him falling off
his ass and shooting JFK in the back of
the head or JFK wouldn't have been dead
because the shot that went through his
chest that's why all those shots look so
weird the way he's moving well now the
Secret Service knows that when John
Kennedy or John Robert Kennedy shows up
he realizes what happened they tell him
like Hey there really was an assassin
there was really an attempt on them
that's not the bull that killed him
though it's our guy who did it so and so
the Wrangler like oh man well I'm not
putting that guy on the stand they're
going to ask who are you what's your job
that's going to embarrass the Kennedy
family he's out just this is the guy
wrangles up [ __ ] for John yeah so
they're like go ahead and throw it all
on him get the bullet backs that's why
they went in there and They confiscated
the one bullet you go and keep the one
you can keep that one but you can't keep
the the five five six round so they're
saying so there was really a guy trying
to make an attempt and the reason why
there's so much convolution around it is
because there was a cover-up but a
cover-up because it was embarrassing and
more of a [ __ ] I like this spin I like
it did you watch the the JFK doc that um
what's his name who did it Barry no uh
the big boy on Showtime or HBO
are you talking about the one who did uh
no uh what's his name he did JFK he did
the movie JFK yeah come on bro come on
you watch that documentary dude it the
evidence that he has so all the evidence
like the bullet the Magic Bullet they
have to put in they have to put in data
when they get it and they trace the
bullet where it went through and all
this it's well if that was all real but
the reason why like it makes it even
more confusing is because all that [ __ ]
was real but the bullet that really hit
him in the back of the head Molly caveat
with that Frank the first bullet goes
through here right so he goes like he
goes through the throat and then he goes
right so the first bullet turns around
and shoots him the driver turns out and
shoots him like the first bullet knocked
him the One Direction because that
really came from Lee Harvey so it's the
second bullet when he buckles forwards
like well how's it a magic Blue Book
that's because that's the kid falling
back okay I'm not mad at the spirit will
you believe that do you believe that
theory sounds plausible
versus just a second shooter what about
the grassy Hill because
like I just feel like yes to all that
plus a drunk screw-up they're all
partying and it makes a little bit
stupid caveat that I also think of Jack
Ruby who was you know he owned a
nightclub where a lot of Mafia guys well
actually they had to cover the Lee
Harvey aspect of it and that's what Jack
Ruby was involved getting there and
killing well the crazy thing is that
Jack Ruby's therapist was also the
therapist that worked with like uh
Charles Manson yeah so there was an MK
Ultra going on oh dude we go we go down
MK Ultra yeah [ __ ] going on now
the same yeah a lot of people doing it
right now yeah so I think that all that
Katy Perry's weird eyeballs
for sure like kind of like where the
[ __ ] did that come from like well what
was actually just everybody's partying
and the guy that your drug dealer is the
one who fired the bullet do you want
that guy on stand to explain that he's
the one that fired the book like well no
we really because they said well we
really do have the Assassin we really
have a guy that made the attempt but he
didn't actually kill him this guy but
this guy
so many witnesses of that though like
it's like like a dude fell like God they
heard multiple shots
the people like the gun the fire was
from behind us on those yeah
the people there have arguments because
they heard shots behind you yeah it's so
interesting to me man and it's so
obvious it's clearly not what oh yeah
it's not obvious but you know Lee Harvey
Oswald never admitted to it never ever
oh yeah and he looks he genuinely they
wouldn't let any media interview him
ever and then obviously Jack Ruby kills
him Jack Ruby when he was in prison was
like okay I'm ready to tell the full
story I tell you how this went down what
exactly happened and then he
mysteriously passed away from cancer all
they would never let him tell the side
of the story it's it's all so
interesting yeah and then also the way
they controlled the other the other
Kennedy brother is he was going hard on
the mafia yeah who got JFK into you know
the family so you know the the Kennedys
were Bootleggers yeah Jack Kennedy gave
them the presidency that he had a stroke
and then the two kids started going
harder correct but they got all their
their income through uh like they're
they're selling alcohol so you think
about their connections there with the
model yeah the mafia like we're gonna
get your son into the the seat of the
white house but he can't come for us JFK
got there turned on him his brother
really turned on in Dallas yeah really
Tom that's what he in there but the
brother wanted to go hard on the paint
on them and they were like cool you can
do that if you do this we're going to
release all the stuff we have on your
brother and you know your brother and
that's why he kind of backed off and
then I'll say he was murdered as well
JFK was bisexual
that's a hot take from Sam I don't know
if I believe that yeah I do he's a real
ladies man no dude
once a week Marilyn Monroe both brothers
and the Chicago Mafia bus at the same
time yeah well by the way Hillary
Clinton's dad uh oh get ready Frank get
ready I'm listening you two uh run the
uh Chicago Mafia
when uh what's his face went to jail who
was the biggest Al Capone her dad took
it over is that true yeah well I only
state facts
yeah dude he used to run the mob and
that's all then don't get me started JFK
was JFK was bisexual since since uh JFK
I'd say there's at least one two three
gay guys no two gay guys and two
bisexual presidents
well Hoover was uh well he was CIA well
uh he started the FBI right no was it
was the head of the uh or FBI he started
FBI division he was head FBI but he was
a gay man yeah I know there's a
cross-dresser yeah yeah no Chad groover
stuff bro but yeah a lot of butt stuff
but uh you would have got hit with a
hammer JFK yeah JFK and Bill Clinton
bisexual and then uh George Bush Senior
and Obama gay interesting Obama's a hot
take there
now this now this do you ever see the
video with the guys
sucked his dick you ever see that you
ever see that press conference no he
sounds super credible though
she wanted there's a press conference
guys like I smoke crack and sucked off
Obama really anyway we believe the
crackhead
great fight
oh do you guys ever see the uh here's a
weird Obama have you ever seen the
people that they think are Obama's kids
real parents have you ever seen that
that's a hot tank what do you mean you
said you're saying his parents weren't
really where they're from was he born in
Hawaii Obama's in Chicago is a bush his
grandparents were bushes his mother
I know that's not because Google
I did I did it you've been away so long
you've forgotten the one hold on such a
hot take let me get this straight Sam
let me just break this down real quick
his parents were actually uh related to
the bushes George Bush's I mean Barack
Obama's mother was an MK Ultra sex
kitten then her grand his grandfather
you guys listen I'm about to make a MK
ultra sexy and t-shirt yeah there we go
so she basically his grandfather used
his mother as a like a spy sex kitten
that will go in and uh compromise people
oh she's Honeypot and fools yeah and
Obama's grandfather was
cousins with um George Bush Senior and
they basically founded the CIA and this
is an interesting fact the the common
ancestor that the Obama's grandfather
and uh George Bush their first common
ancestors guess who Nancy Pelosi no
a Hinckley
no way yeah I want to assassinate well
again right yeah yeah
they had dinner with the hinckleys the
night before he's out of jail now yeah
he's making music we should have him on
so that sell more takes a lot of
comments yeah sell more than me I asked
him if he wants co-head have them open
up
yeah there's a bunch of pictures you can
find but uh those are the two people
that follow the the Obamas around
everywhere and those are the Obama kids
because he wasn't able to Father song
She's a dude I've seen I've seen that
stuff get your mind right okay I'm
trying to keep up man
yeah
the Michelle Obama's a dude thing is
huge on the internet I've seen pictures
and stuff you know what's interesting
too is I I don't shut the stuff that I
used to because Rogan used to shut a lot
of it down because the original fight
command Eddie was on there and Eddie
would you know yeah
but then what's interesting is now in
Hindi I look back and I I talk to Eddie
all the time he was he was right on most
of it and I'll never forget this is the
most embarrassing I ever did on any
podcast me and Eddie are arguing about
something he you know he called you know
Obama Elizabeth person whatever and then
I was like Eddie you're out of your mind
man because Rogue was like stop Eddie
Stop I was like Eddie you're out of your
mind and then he goes all right where do
you get your news and it's the most
embarrassing I'll go CNN Eddie you
thought his head was gonna explode he
was yeah CNN that is it when maybe
Foxy's like you're out of your mind yeah
he's like freaking out but everything
Eddie said back in those if you go watch
he's pretty spot on dude yeah I mean
where does Eddie get his news
that's what I said well you tell me it
he goes I'll tell you after and he was
just too drunk and I forgot
I'm definitely signing off on Trudeau
being a Castro kid though oh yeah that's
for sure
okay you don't have to but now
study it this is ridiculous like this is
the bottom one what about uh the uh
Harry and uh with the the uh uh Megan
Marco yeah his dad the real dad yeah
they do cockapalooza you've ever seen
that one no everybody
is his dad also a freaking redhead is
like Captain in this military like he
was like the horse riding instructor for
uh
uh Diana and like you show pictures of
them side by side you're like oh dude he
looks nothing like his brother looks
nothing like nothing like that and you
see like Woody Allen that's why you see
like is it which one's the way I always
forget Harry right yeah uh or William or
yeah
William's the older one yeah so Henry's
the redhead one right Harry's the right
here yeah you ever see like he's like
he's an alpha dude like I remember they
were doing an interview with him and
he's sitting there and he's in his
uniform because you know he was a
helicopter they have to right all of a
sudden like dudes are like running off
and he like pulls tipped out yeah he's
like I'm out those days are gone he got
with Meghan Markle and she just owns his
nuts she just was like she owns them
like that transgender in Thailand with
Callen
yeah it's kind of hard to watch I think
she was an escort I mean when she like
she started that podcast and and I was
reading about it and it was like this
podcast is about the challenges that
women face in America and the first
person that I'm going to have on is uh
is uh Serena Williams I was like oh what
a [ __ ] tough life she has perfect
example of it being really hard to be a
woman in America get the [ __ ] out of
here dude yeah and he juices so worth
like [ __ ] 300 million dollars how do
you how are you uh like the number one
female athlete to your 40 in uh tennis
those girls like disintegrate at like 30
right I mean it's just the way I think
look we have genetic freaks in the world
it's just that because of drugs where
there's one out of a thousand where now
there's like a hundred out of a thousand
but 99 of them run I love Serena there
is the one they're all outliers
yeah look at Francis that dude's drug
tested like a mofo now gun to the Head
you know gun to the Head it'd be tough
to say she's just because it's Pro you
know we've been in Pro Sports I know so
many people it's just like getting ahead
I'd be like yo I don't want to die and
here's my theory man she did something
depends what you consider a PD If plants
what's an [ __ ] would they have ever
really pressed it because
so I I have this theory that certain
guys no are you loud not allowed but I
think people had a vendetta because of
how evil he was right people like [ __ ]
but everybody when people like try to
disclose about his drug abuse and you
know and use and even though like look
when they I remember that was it either
him or Floyd they stripped him of the
title they went down okay who's the
number two police drug test they have to
go down to 18 francs yeah right so
everyone in that so I'm like all right
let's just go ahead and say that it
wasn't even playing field guys but
because of the way he like people that
he was an [ __ ] yeah like he like
destroyed lives
yeah like it was like Yo dude he's
learned from it he's a better person
which to me like that's America dude
come back story still like Lance
Armstrong now who I actually I love the
dude he has a podcast and you know
especially during you know like uh the
Tour de France stuff it gets really big
he has a podcast you hear him talk and
it's just like you know you just there's
part of you feels bad from the way he
was treated and he talks especially
because everybody was doing it it wasn't
like he really was he wasn't the outlet
no that's what he was saying he's like
he's like man now he goes I made some
mistakes the way I treated he just was
the champion he's like as far as speed
well he's like he was part of an [ __ ]
he was the number one guy so he had a
Target on his back yeah
I'll tell you as a Target on the back
and I'm dressed like a Michael Myers
sure is scary but the last thing you
need to be is hairy this Halloween don't
be all hairy like Andre olowsky for
Halloween dude luckily my friends at
manscape launched their fourth
generation performance package to make
sure your pumpkins get the ultimate
carving experience on this spooky day
you're ready for a lot of Halloween
references kids turn your bite-sized
tree to a king-sized candy and join the
6 million Bros worldwide who dress
manscape by going to manscape.com for 20
off and free shipping with the code
shop20 make the right call this spooky
season it's trick or trim don't have a
hairy wiener all right have you ever
tried to trim your nuts and turn into
Freddy Krueger film another Halloween
reference well luckily manscaped is here
to save the day their lawnmower 4.0
their performance package 4.0 you get
the only thing that should be touched in
your genitals all right lawnmower 4.0
has a light on it it won't Nick your
nuts it does wonders for you and then
also it comes with the weed whacker it's
a total Game Changer Frank and Sam could
use it it should it gets rid of the hair
in your ears and nose both you could use
it right uh the weed whacker it knows in
here trimmer it's fantastic they also
give you the crop preserver ball
deodorant the crop reviver boat ball
toner will make sure your pumpkins stay
fresh another Halloween reference just
when I say this fellas your balls will
thank you manscape Gosser just launched
a new body buffer that's 100
antibacterial body scrubber and they
even threw in two free gifts when you
get the performance package you get the
manscape boxes which I love the shed
travel bag all right so you can put it
all in there man get 20 off in free
shipping the coach shop20 atmanscape.com
if you're going to shave your region the
lower region what else are you going to
use what are you from the 90s it's
manscape or bus dude that's 20 off free
shipping with code shop20 at
manscape.com say Trick-or-Treat to your
beautiful new Halloweeny with manscape
love it dude manscape sponsors my
channel you should definitely use shop
20 promo code but I can I can sign off
on that product for sure oh dude yeah I
used it earlier today I'm dressed like
Michael Myers I dress like gray I'm just
like Michael Myers if you struggle with
his pronouns yeah yeah sure I'm losing
I'm in the three yeah that story that uh
Elon Musk went around to Twitter asked
people for their pronouns and anyone who
gave pronouns they fired him if that's
true that's amazing that's the best have
you seen one you know you gather
everybody up and was like all right
you're fired everybody crying yeah she's
the one lady in the back she's like the
yeah she's behind it all she's all
should you just see like the hurt on her
face now she did get a 17 million 40
million or something like that no he are
you talking about yo got 48 million
that's right she's the chief content
officer yeah the one that went on like
the Indian lady yeah yeah yeah you just
see the her she dude she's the reason
Trump got kicked off she's the reason
why Alex Alex Bro did you see Trump he
trumps a comedian dude did you see his
tweet when Elon took over Twitter
on truth on Truth social or I don't know
what is the one where he ended with the
uh my brother said to me he's like he's
out of he's like this dude is a comic
because he put uh I'm honored to see an
African-American own a business like
Twitter because it's right yeah you're
from South Africa yeah he's American so
African-American it's so ridiculous it's
just he's a comic yeah that's what he is
he's hilarious yeah
it's crazy bro
crazy I love new Twitter this guy quit
on the seat didn't come out or his uh
his his trainer was you know what the
problem is though Sam on Twitter is uh
it's not really it's not like the the IT
thing right you know Twitter's just not
it's never been like the it for a while
was the but now it's like nobody really
uses Twitter so for Comics I guess
promote dates Twitter ain't the move
elon's gonna start adding new features
yeah if he had features we can post like
you know better uh you know pictures and
videos then maybe it's gonna grow
because especially because you know it's
not this weird dictatorship because I'm
like I feel like you know it's almost
just political and social commentary
and it's just talk but he's gonna come
up with her I I listen I hope it doesn't
go back to where you could just like
suddenly you're scrolling and then
there's like some gang bang scene right
there like I want that but but I think
he is going to have some regulation like
obviously kid the racist stuff and the
bigotry and like the the the the anti uh
gay stuff that get rid of that but as
far as just opinions but when you say
that dude it's a very slippery slope man
because what what are you going to stop
all racial discussion are you going to
be like are you gonna stop those black
comics from doing white jokes no there's
a big difference Sam because if if
they're using the N word if the Y case
in the n-word we can't you can have it
on Twitter right I understand that but
if it's anti-semitis then we start going
back to making these rules well now the
rules are really now it's like anything
goes do we do I want to be on a platform
where people are calling each other the
m words no but it's also like you're
just gonna start if you start doing that
again so what do you do this hard once
you start to censor things because it's
one of those things that like well
I hear that it's a problem there's
definitely a discussion we need to have
but one thing I'd like to try to get
away from is that people feel entitled
to not be offended anymore yes like if
you offend me somehow that's enough
that's a felony for you don't if you
offend me I want to take your livelihood
I'm going to try and cancel yeah you
know you have no we're going to just go
for you because I read things all the
time that I don't agree with or I find
offensive I mean there's some things
that I you know and I obviously can't
say out loud because I'll be canceled
you know but I have some thoughts about
how people raise their children and yes
and some things that are about they're
probably on a racial level as far as
we're talking about different
discussions and whatnot but but like so
when people say certain things I'm like
wow that really is just [ __ ] and or
stupid and I don't like to hear it I
just click off of it I don't finish the
article
you know why I don't go after the person
who wrote the article I don't care
you're the successful person all right
I'm gonna move on to the next people
that go after people are doing that they
have nothing else to do so it's
literally they're consumed with it I
guess I don't have the energy for it
it's part of their culture like they
honestly believe that like like if
someone that they disagree with is
coming to speak on campus they're like
it's our responsibility to shut down
their event and you're like you know I
just saw a thing where there was rich
kids it was a woman talking in an
article they had a bunch of you know
purple-haired liberals sitting in the
audience and the lady was sitting there
go like to sit there and say for example
that there's no difference between men
and women yeah yeah right there was that
discussion she goes men are naturally
are on average taller than women is
anybody going to argue that fact that on
average men are taller than more muscle
mass fat disposition she's like our
brains are also different you know like
there are differences that you will
accept but then like people start
getting up and they the one guy got so
mad like he destroyed like one of the
cameras and pulled on I'm like wait a
minute like if someone like I have
thoughts that get changed all the time
there's times if someone will say
something like what do you think about
this Frank I'm like I think X like well
have you taken this into consideration
I'll listen to them I'm like no I
haven't yeah you open minded yeah let me
go ahead let me change my view you know
what's an IQ thing yeah I'm like oh okay
you know what I was wrong and now I feel
I want to adjust my belief it's like
fighting me going hey I think this
choke's the best choke in the world
they're not gonna roll with you and like
next thing I know I'm waking up on the
mat going that didn't work out too well
did it like well I'm gonna what did I do
wrong like well you should have done
this should have done that okay I'm
gonna make an adjustment because I would
rather just have a better choke I'm not
gonna sit and argue that well this
joke's awesome just you must have done
this or you know and try to you know to
pad the you know the the conversation in
some way that's like well yeah we're not
going to take this into consideration so
that's the part like where I sit there
like well how do you guys like not want
to listen to things and that's offensive
and that's angry but it's like man like
when the lady was talking I sat I was
like wow that's a really good point on
average men are taller their way of the
highway and it's like that's insane yeah
but it's all rich kids and this is just
I I believe we and I was talking to
Calum bought this yesterday it's like
everybody like we just had this basic
fight and flight in US I mean gallon's a
rich kid but yeah and yeah and that's
what makes the show work but as you go
slower lower and lower down the the uh
the uh economic levels the fight and
flight gets more and more real right and
then like you're on my screen yes and
it's really real you really have
problems
kids now create you know racism
microaggressions everywhere uh climate
change all these things that are never
gonna have you seen that video where the
guy goes and interviews a bunch of uh uh
college kids like in Brown University
somewhere like that real real liberal
area right he goes do you think that you
know voter ID is I've seen that right
and no it's racist because you know some
people don't have access to the internet
don't have phones can't figure out where
to go like really kind of like I'm like
wow that's kind of offensive it's super
racist dude like wow like yeah
wow out of all my friends that are black
I don't know any of them it doesn't have
the internet or doesn't know how to go
doesn't know where the DMV is and then
so then they go back like downside like
in a like an urban area
okay like hey like could you like and
the person's like look [ __ ] I
have a cell phone yeah the internet's
right here who doesn't know how to just
based off just based off that way of
thinking just it's a numbers game it's
not a rich thing you know there's more
poor white people than black people it's
just numbers things yeah it's more that
makes sense yeah there's way more white
people so can we play a game that's all
right so if you're if it's a fast thing
and shall we play a game for poor black
people have phones was more according to
your belief there would be more white
people poor white people out yeah who
typically even you know vote Republican
yeah yeah
why do you not want people to have to
show an ID to vote like you know you
know what someone said to me the other
day you know like certain people all
certain arguments like wow that was good
if you're so confident about mail-in
ballots you're a bad person then go
ahead
cyborg so put 500 an envelope yeah and
mail it to yourself yeah like how
confident do you feel about that like
it's not
oh yeah that kind of because you know
like I've been kind of on the phone and
stuff I'm like ah really you know like I
don't know you know what I mean like has
there ever been you know explicit proof
that there's ever been you know a lot
you know so I have an open mind I'll
listen you know but when they said that
and control them there yeah it's easier
to control it's easy you know what I'm
saying yeah instead of physical people
going up the mail there's more it's
easier well there's certain times I hear
people freak out it's because they don't
really understand the situation like
we're like oh well you know this guy was
winning at this moment then all of a
sudden I'm like well that's because the
mail-in votes were counted at started at
midnight you know what I mean like so
that would make sense that that number
who majority of more Democrats you know
so like I'm like that's just just the
situation I don't know if that
necessarily alluded to the election was
[ __ ] rigged it was 100 rig listen
every election is rigged every election
is rigged it's just on left and right
though everyone whoever whoever rigs it
best wins yeah
foreign
they're all on the same team I think
they all eat lunch together it's pro
wrestling it's all K fab right they keep
us fighting with each other so we don't
throw them exactly because it's like
that old like like really honestly it's
like a cartoon where the [ __ ] like oh
well they ever figure out that they
outnumber us it's like you realize it
like there's only like 600 people you
know in the whole government yeah you
know what I mean like if you count every
government you have real power yeah the
Senate the the you know okay okay you
know the 600 or so
you know there's 360 million Americans
you know what I mean like if we ever sat
there and go stop fighting with each
other and be like okay well if we wanted
to we could overthrow that because I sit
there and talk about like I see the
thing about racism like you know what I
don't know anybody you know I live in
Vegas you know what I mean like I
honestly don't have a friend black white
hispanic you know you name it that
actually hates another group of people
like right explicitly just oh man you
know look at that guy over there like I
hate Chinese guys
these extreme groups online
yeah I think
I think originally because he's like
right you have to tell me how many Bots
yeah like oh we can't do that number
he's like I'm not buying it apparently
it's the numbers not 80 percent dude if
you go into listen everyone's like
everybody's like rushing Bots and
rushing this dude the Pentagon just got
busted completely AstroTurf we all do it
right so everybody has media completely
astro turf oh yeah you know the best uh
like hackers dude they [ __ ] fake
beheading videos they got the CIA got
busted giving help hey what about the
gas bill tax in Syria complete [ __ ]
dude Red Line Red Line dude they got all
the gas that was used was from [ __ ]
mobile Gaddafi those videos I saw the
syrians or all the kids and stuff yeah
that's all dude that was fakes the gas
that ruined my day too I don't think I
talked for a day after I watched it I
like I close the door like and I had
like a dark like the world yeah you just
saw these women children people kids
like just and that Dad was sitting by
himself like that yeah it was horrendous
and I'm watching this video I'm like I
hate the world you know what I mean like
I wish I was Superman I'd go and
Crushers
and tested the chemicals and they were
like these are not the chemicals that
Assad has because they knew what
chemicals he had and it was more like
mobile and Gaddafi's basically Armory
and they they totally had faked it I
mean so much in the Ukraine right now is
is like now it's like a real technique I
get it you know what I mean yeah
all right
intense well if you want to get in the
zone like Sam and Frank right here and
rip off some conspiracies you can do
that somehow much conspiracy no I'm into
it Sammy I'm into it brother no please
don't that's why you're here brother
it's interesting man uh you have a right
to do it dude and if you want to be in
the zone and maybe you want to scroll
down the dark web and get into things
and get really focused you need the best
nootropics on the planet from my friends
that on it we're talking about Alpha
Brain they're so confident Alpha Brain
is going to work it's money back
guaranteed if you don't like it give
them two weeks tell them why you didn't
like it you can keep it no return
necessary they got you covered they got
you covered that so much they believe in
Alpha Brain my boy Joe Rogan says it
helps them form better sentences you
want to talk like Joe Rogan we all do
well if we're bringing you one step
closer to spelling and thinking like Joe
Rogan now for bringing him pick it up at
Walmart but you don't want to go to
Walmart right so do your boy a real
solid go to onnit.com CFC pick up the
best Alpha Brain in the planet we're
talking about the nootropic
of the best ever from on it that's on
it.com CFC save 10 off everything on it
we're talking about workout gear best
supplements protein powder Warrior bars
multivitamins uh kettlebells steel maces
they got it all they got battle ropes
they got everything but if you want to
try the Alpha Brain the best nootropic
on the planet go to onnit.com CFC
yeah man dude is this at the same uh the
same place that did UFC 274 yeah same
yeah I think so that's a nice that's a
nice joint my thing is if if Jake Paul
wins this where's he go from here either
Nate Diaz or or a real boxer probably
Nate Diaz oh yeah no idea is fights with
that one 100 100 and you know again I'm
not taking anything I'm not taking any
credit for this but Jake's a buddy of
mine right and uh Jake came to my shop
and friends at the Hollywood improv you
might have been on it Sam he's in the
green room I don't know if you saw him
there I was in there so at the time he
was doing the scene where he's calling
out uh Michael Bisping I said Jake let
me talk to you yeah it's about it
that's a bad like a box yeah Mike can
trust me can [ __ ] fight dude so but I
told you you I know you say you don't
care about getting validation from the
MMA Community I said there can be a
worse way to go about it Michael Bisby
has one eye two fake knees dude like and
he's moved on he's a great podcast he's
one of the best analysts in the world
don't go for him you're not going to get
a respect that the guy's one freaking
eye yeah I said you want respect and he
was just coming off the Julio Chavez Jr
fight you go go for Anderson he's older
but he's a Legend So striking Jake Paul
gets starched it's your fault my fault
no if if Jake Paul beats Anderson at
this point the Nate Diaz fight for just
you know and then maybe a Conor fight
you know type yeah
I would have I would have thought I'd
seen Connor lately
well what happened
he's out of you saw the testing pool
complete so uh Paul George just sent us
in he says it says there's a broadcast
did this just happen yeah yeah tonight
bro a few minutes yeah oh he said I mean
listen Diaz is so smart if there wasn't
a brawl that would be very poor
they didn't do a brawl
no that's great dude I love Sloan his
daughters are beautiful yeah they are
you know they they use the the old
finally Kids Studio do the podcast oh
really they had the red chairs in there
forever yeah they're great is that the
only video of that of the brawl that's
the one I found first but there might be
another one yeah I would assume Nate
Diaz is next with Nate stuff but then
honestly I think what Jesse said I think
he would have to step into like then
facing a top ranked box or an Awakening
top right like like a top 10 guy well no
I think a bad idea no I think that you'd
fight a legitimate one you know some guy
was ten and five or you know you know
that's legitimately moving his way I've
made ten and two type you know and then
yeah I mean what's next from after that
like go try to win a boxing time I was
gonna say if Jake is gets serious and
he's like I want to win a title and he
like does well and starts knocking a
couple guys out like dude he'll get a
lot of attention I mean he's like okay
the Nate Diaz is a huge fight for him as
far as popularity how do you think that
goes Frank before you gone
um I think that's I think that's a tough
isn't that interesting fight yeah I
think that's a tough fight for uh for
for Jake too just because the volume
volume is just people don't realize what
it's like to get pestered by a guy that
doesn't stop throwing pumpkin
is slower I'm sorry renate is slower
yeah he's definitely slower yeah like
against Tony Ferguson he was not used to
have a razor fast though it wasn't like
he was no but also but even his output
like he he's he's what I think what
makes Nate successful now especially
against Tony's he's adapted to you know
he's older he's lost maybe step yeah but
his style he's fine Tony style when
father time comes you're screwed the
athletic ability the explosive enough
that goes out the window yeah but Nate
really adapted well to his age
I I do and Nate and his brother can box
dude like they were training with Andre
Ward so I think for Jake it could be
tough but again Jake's so young it's so
hard he's fast dude he but he's fast but
he hits hard yeah yeah he hits hard so
I'm interested like this is my question
the MMA Community now I don't think
he'll ever get his uh credit ever he
could knock out canal and people like oh
canelo's just coming off a loss he's not
[ __ ] or whatever who knows it's never
gonna he's never gonna get the credit he
deserves but I think he would win some
fans over if he beats it let's say he
starts his answering tonight yeah and
then he knocks out Nate the the the the
the the the
the Talk's still going to be well these
guys aren't boxers what if he takes an
MMA fight though
I think he will he says well he has an
office
Jake Paul yeah he was Cash in checks and
living the best life give a [ __ ] if
anyone thinks he's not fighting real
boxers I mean like dude because money
money's already taken care of so do you
now you want respect dude yeah do you
want to get knocked down look but as
guys that go and I take Crawford I mean
like there is that party that wants to
be respected especially yeah you can say
what you want but I'm like yeah but
you're doing it you know what I mean the
fact that you're doing this with the
lights camera and you're walking in that
ring you could tell me you don't care
what people think but like then why are
you fighting yeah you could just go have
Jim Moore the same with comedy like like
your fan like a fan system or like a
lower level comic system who's I do not
it doesn't bother me at all but if like
Bill Burr came at me I would I would
never do comedy again if Bill Burr like
Rogan came at me I'd be like Oh I'm out
you want the respect from the the guys
at the highest level like you calling
I just played a gay bar in Jacksonville
don't worry about me Jacksonville that's
what that's when you know Jacksonville
is tough yeah bro I love Florida though
I'll do that I love Florida oh dude yeah
the light Crowds Are the worst well
right now you think they heard you and
they switched the girl out oh yeah yeah
oh I feel bad let's listen she's sitting
on a stool now yeah you ruined a career
not the fans I'll subscribe the guy
calls it hey get Tummy out of the ring
dude this guy's a minion my kids would
love this hopefully he's doing it for
kids it's okay I'm not gonna say it no
go ahead no we've already been demons
you guys demonetize it I'm sorry bro oh
no who knows listen all my Show's good
what do you got please nothing nope Sam
do it no that's why you're here dude no
don't be that guy too dark Nazi aliens
go do this full Sam the minions are
based on uh Holocaust uh suits okay
who's
Sam can you explain the Kanye thing to
me without getting canceled what do you
want to know what do you think I think
Kanye's trying to get out contracts
that's exactly what but he crossed the
line that he can't come back from like
his whole goal for all this and he
talked about it and he even went once
you get out of the Adidas contract yes
because he went on um the drink Champs
podcast they're amazing great show shout
out to them he went on there and he was
like I didn't be anti-semitic and you're
still not going to do anything he knows
they're gonna do something that's him he
wants full ownership
my only issue with that my brother's the
biggest kind of fan me and him were
arguing Canada last night about it I
said my only issue is and I like Kanye I
see Kanye all the time my thing was is
you signed the contract it's like UFC
fighters yeah you're selling these new
six five deals they're two fights in it
like they're not payment if it's like
well where was this energy when he
signed up two months ago Dude like if
that's the time to fight so for Connie
like you signed all these deals now you
realize how much money they're making
there's a reason that's it right there
now you realize like I mean you got to
admit perspective changes as you get
older and you yeah well and for Fighters
like your value changes I think for
Kanye that argument is even more like
solid like it's on Solid Ground it's
like dude you made that deal but
remember Kanye's always kind of done
this polarizing stuff it's just and when
you hit the White lives matter I'm like
right he should be fine with that before
that remember he even said things about
black people was like slavery was a
choice apparently said something about
Hitler that they edit out of the TMZ
thing he went hard on you know he said
slavery was a choice yeah yeah that was
the big one so but the black community
really didn't cancel for that they put
up with that put up with what I mean
there are certain slave cultures that
slavery was this was like slavery in
America is much different yeah so we can
definitely talk about not American
slavery no that wasn't a joke but yeah
we can go down there it gets dicey but
uh with the anti-semitic that's he
messed with the wrong voice yeah yeah
all generalizations I hate it all but
always or never right yeah I hate it but
he's what's upset me about like 1834
that's good
it's him versus dad that's me and Brian
fighting right now that guy is it's his
dad
what was that guy 26 years older 16. so
you got that you know you're making this
generalization 26.
34. 12 plus I mean are we doing more
yeah 16. you're right I was right okay
no go ahead sorry go Sam and go number
one it's like everyone's losing their
mind on Kanye so upset the blue check
mark [ __ ] retards right just losing
their [ __ ] mind they're all fine with
like we have a a white privilege problem
a white supremacy a male toxicity
problem uh me too like other total
generalizations you're doing the exact
same thing the exact same thing and you
were perfectly fine not only were you
fine with it you were rewarded for doing
it and now it's going the other way and
I don't agree with any of it but now
it's going the other way now you're
losing your mind you're running around
crazy I think that's one everybody gets
a free pass on you can say anything
about white guys well it's the exact
same thing it's the exact same thing and
it's just like this is I think
everything in in on the Internet or in
pop culture goes to an extreme that
makes no sense and then it comes back to
a common sense thing
we're gonna I think you're seeing the
end of political correctness Elon taken
over Twitter is so huge because Twitter
just served as this like obviously by
the way my own stock and Twitter oh you
bought it what like a while ago not that
not that cheap but I knew it was gonna
happen yeah I mean he's not gonna say
though Jesse the the I Twitter's value
is that they can manufacture the idea
that people all agree on [ __ ] that they
don't you know like that's why they can
get like they can get politicians to sit
there and be they're like uh what do you
what's the definition of a woman they're
all [ __ ] I don't know man I don't know
what a woman is because they think that
if they say it because they have all
these bots on Twitter they're all well
[ __ ] cancel they're not even real
yeah they're they're saying they're
saying on Twitter like I think I'm like
at 700 000 followers on there they're
saying because Twitter's so like weird
with all the following stuff they said
having like six to seven hundred
thousand on twitters like having damn
near 2 million on Instagram because of
the weird things that they do oh really
yeah so your number's almost doubled as
far as getting exposure but again as
comments we really leader I'll post it
but I really don't use it you always
hear people say like cancer culture is
not real they're right it's not real but
they're saying it for the wrong reasons
no but it is real because the
corporations
it's real if if that's why we have
friends who suffer from this we have
friends it is real because the
corporations create the create the
illusion because of Twitter I have some
friends Twitter friends that got
canceled it is real because the
corporation goes all my friends we
believe you but we just want to deal
with the backlash yeah we're out it's
like what like we just want to deal with
it we'd rather not deal with it
I think Twitter's like the central place
for background that's what they're
scared of can we talk about canceling
too like I think if someone really
stands behind their thoughts and I agree
with this people don't like what you say
that's just life that's just to me
that's just you know that's uh hey this
is a capitalism you know yeah you have a
product that people don't want it
doesn't get bought you know what I mean
like so if but the problem I have with
is when some like allegations come out
or and it's hearsay and then people get
their careers ruined with no solidiful
uh Solitude off a tweet yeah see like
you know that's when I get upset about
like wait a minute I thought we had
these you know those trials type thing
yeah I agree I agree but but not but
corporations are so scared in Hollywood
so scared they're like we'd rather just
not deal with it yeah you're out yeah
it controls people to make people afraid
to questions so you create this illusion
that this small group and if you're
asking me bro I think the woke
Progressive left is like America oh wow
34 year old sorry guys it's good yeah
thank God 34 by 30. oh you got a liver
shot he must have seven oh so I like the
ref Still Counting
oh yikes
you know it's gonna be fun about
watching this kid him getting more and
more tattoos as he goes yes dude Jake's
got a bunch of new ink now yeah like
here and well if he's not boxing he's
nothing he's bored in Costa Rica got to
spend some money yep
I can't believe in California man they
take half your money I'm like nine I get
it yeah I agree with that I'll take you
to Puerto Rico they're getting like they
constantly get like hammered by
hurricanes yeah that is like the the
weather really no taxes but he just
flies here yeah and then when the
Hurricanes already flies back
yeah oh yeah they lose power for like
weeks sometimes I mean if you have a
badass generator yeah all the places
gone off Puerto Rico is the move but
listen it's like what three it's like
three percent tax total or something
like that something crazy like that I
mean in Texas there's no there's no
state income tax well they get you on
the state tax right
where uh Texas
Federal yeah but there's no state income
tax and then like and then property tax
I think is property tax
I wish that show a replay but they
really they read the value is punching
the canvas like that made me feel like
you must get caught with a bottle yeah
because usually when you get rocked yeah
that's when your body and your head's
active but your body just your legs are
just shot that face is every bit of 67.
yeah
my daughter's watching hi munchkin no
the daughter's watching the the ninja
and uh ghost yeah goes to ninja I came
up with dude
are you guys coming out next week to the
fights at FFN
no you're in San Antonio I know I know
that because I'm going oh yeah I'm going
to San Antonio
San Antonio I'm there at the LOL next
Thursday Friday Saturday and the week
after I'm in Houston what's great about
Texas the biggest market for Tiger thick
so I'm doing appearance in Houston at
specs when all the specs out there but
at the shows like Calgary's a nightmare
the tiger thick six cases got stopped at
Customs they just went allow it through
who knows but in Texas San Antonio this
is my biggest market so we'll have all
the cases so for Santo Houston San
Antonio is at the LOL next Thursday
Friday Saturday Houston's next the the
following week Thursday Friday Saturday
Houston Improv we'll have all the
freaking tiger thick that sweet thick
nectar award-winning nectar and if
you're not in Texas you can get online
at uh thickboy.com delivered to your
house
yeah and I'll be I'll be at that show
Saturday night yeah for sure be fun man
Hannah was great when's the last time
you played Canada Sam ever since Trudeau
wants nuts well they they just opened up
right so that was that loud like there's
no there's no guidelines now no now they
now if you don't if you don't have the
yeah I've seen here's what's crazy so
they don't check vaccines at all but if
you're Canadian to get to because
America we still require Canadians and
international people wait we still do if
they come America does Canada doesn't
it's ridiculous well they dude it was
only just a short time ago
it wasn't body shape
that would make sense right why they
replay the whole fight well I mean it's
not real I just want to see the part
yeah come on you know I've never
isolated the virus right you know that
right I don't okay I don't know enough
about HIV
they never isolated it
is okay this is the punch block okay
gloves minions oh it's a left hook yeah
that's a chin shot there oh that's bad
man yeah I'm with you Frank it's where
do you slap in the the kids yeah
that's a weird one right weird one but
you know Jesse called the two percent
because he like was really wobbly and
then they called the fight and then it
was really straight yeah yeah and then
they fell again so I'm like
what's the uh what are the odds that uh
someone's gonna just take one on the
chin on purpose yeah
hey uh Jesse Frank Sam let me know what
you think how you guys feeling now about
the sugar Shawn decision I love him bro
in the world now here's my okay
according to how the judges are supposed
to judge and that's how I'm trying to
look at it now damn it this whole damage
thing and then quantity and then uh
control he won the first round too I
mean like he landed because look it's
very biased towards striking really the
new way of judging right so like you
know I'm fighting somebody and I I take
them down I pass their guard I put him
in a head and arm and they roll out of
it stand up they throw one kicked in my
Stern and I fall back they're winning
the fight 100 like what damage did I
cost you my takedown on my submit now I
think how I would look at a fight in my
opinion
my Jan won the first round but like how
I judged for also a grappling expert
yeah right like looking at the whole
picture I mean I understand boxing I've
done professional boxing I mean like I
get it I understand the whole aspect of
MMA from the grappling of the strike and
so I see the big picture and I'm like oh
in the big picture Peter Yan won the
first round according to what I think a
fight should be but that's not what
they're judging the judge's criteria I
think they got it right that's what I
said I said based off what the the way
they judge a fight if you guys don't
like that decision change
and that's what I said I said I didn't
invent the rules but I know I'm just I'm
going based off what um
do the criterias like I was watching I
was watching the Tim Means fight with
chin and I was like did Tim win by the
way he lost split decision but dude the
third he's literally he's on his back
moving from submission attempt to
submission attempt he must have landed a
hundred shots from his back and I'm like
and then I'm like watch them give it to
this other guy and I bet on the other
dude I was like just please let these
judges be [ __ ] morons and they were
and they give it I mean it's I no I've
actually been I don't want to throw them
under the bus right but I've I've
friends that have been back my girl and
the judges are talking amongst
themselves right and again right and so
they were watching a fight and basically
some guy shot in got stuck in a
guillotine the guy passed over was on
the wrong the correct side so the
guillotine the guilty was completely
useless to anybody that knows anything
about a submission holder he just held
it forever right well just holding on
the guy said the other guy's needing
them punching them forearm you're like
boom boom was on top who do you think
won most of judges and these are Judges
the judge UFC fights oh the guy had him
in a submission oh no because look think
about it like what is I'll throw her
name out there Adelaide bird what does
she know about grappling reservations
100 anything it's the number one problem
in the sport so like and then the UFC
brass go can't leave in the judge's
decisions like no hold on that's what
they're there for because that's why
they're there for but then also yeah
it happens to be this is pretty [ __ ]
guys I hate that it's like um I don't
know if you failed to watch what was
going on but I was trying to take the
other guy's head off I tried to take
their arm off I tried to choke him to be
a professional they trained for the
fight they showed up in shape number six
in the world I'm telling the world it's
like he's have to put away have you
failed to notice they knew what the hell
they were doing too it's the judges I
ran out of time yeah so then I should be
credited for the fact of I was winning
the fight I didn't leave it up to the
like put No Effects
you know what it is they won't let us in
because I think that I think the the old
the judges are right now the Old Guard
doesn't want us in there people that
actually know what the hell they're
talking about are looking to make them
look bad pretty soon they're going to
look stupid because if they were ever
like get on a podcast and go hey if I
got an ally but let's watch a fight do
you know what's going on right now she
would like what choke is that yeah what
position is that what are they doing
right now oh no I bet you could sit down
with them like Clueless yeah which way
does he need to move to finish that yeah
how do you get out of it who's in
trouble right now simple stuff like is
that Americana or what is that yeah like
a choke right there like that's pretty
simple most most almost every kid at
night Jiu Jitsu class right it drives
those right or Syndicate if I showed
them a person wrapped around the head
and the other person laying crossbody on
them going who's who who's who what's
going on right they're like oh well
bottom person needs to let the head go
because they don't have a choke or
they're gonna get uh but you have judges
there's also a choke for the guys yeah
yeah you have the uh the Von flu right
you're like oh you need to let the head
go but you have people judging UFC fight
level that don't know they're like oh
the person on bottom is winning see they
almost have him in a submission I'm like
wow oh really are you serious you think
that and then the backlash sugar is
getting even sugar count was like it's
not my fault no yeah anybody matters
sugar goes I thought it was a close
fight it was a close fight yeah but the
narrative now on sugar right because he
you know he's polarizing figure which is
a good thing that's why he makes so much
money is now they have a reason to hate
him oh you didn't beat young you didn't
beat yonsic we can't say it's a rock
he's like I'm not was it a robbery and
according to how the criteria that
they've put out there right now he won
the fight yep dude like uh you know
what's the reaction one thing that
O'Malley said is he said he thinks that
he'd be getting more respect right now
if he lost the decision and I actually
agree with that I agree with him yeah
but who gives a [ __ ] what the public
thinks yeah you're the number one
bandwid in the world yeah and you're
fighting for a title next dude yeah who
gives it well they know sahudo is they
said so who knows fighting next well he
came out that's what Dana said yeah oh
probably because they hate that [ __ ]
matchup Al Jermaine and Sean and they
like to Hooters but I mean but they got
it well I think they like shahudo to
beat Al Jermaine and then they like
suhudo versus O'Malley better than
algeman
that's even worse that's even worse but
that's if you're trying to protect
O'Malley I mean if you you want him
like no that's an awful matchup Jesse
they announced that that's a Dana in the
press conference said so who knows next
yeah I bet you they I bet you they
backtracked on a little bit now I love
Henry sahuto or they got to put O'Malley
on the burner because we take a chance
but that's my thing with O'Malley it's
like if you're O'Malley now he's a
business you know and he's ranked number
one so it's right there on top man yeah
who they gonna give you dude because
that Cheeto maybe that next fight's
tough it would be Cheeto if if not
Cheeto Vero yeah the next fight's tough
and and do your chances a just to get
the UFC one in whatever 10 million the
chances to fight for a title asked Frank
world champion the chances to fight for
a title
one percent so for sugar I'm here I'm
going I'm not doing [ __ ] that's probably
smart he has to sit on the burnt back
burner yeah because yeah if he if he
just goes I'm not fighting unless it's
for a title he'll get a title shot
because Cheetos
I can see the narrative on why that
fight could make sense why he's waiting
you know what I mean but like
it's a chance I mean look Jordan's
manager I'm like we're not doing [ __ ]
there's no that's smart he's into a
fight you lose that one well then you're
definitely not gonna fight then fight
another monster in top three yeah you
lose that one we're [ __ ] dude yeah
dude you changed my mind on that
actually I I was thinking that he that
he takes a different but I think you're
right dude no yeah I'm telling you you
don't waste of titles you can sniff a
title shot you're right you hold out
dude yeah yeah you're right because then
that'll change your life
it's way too because where Sugar's at
now his life's not changed there's
sometimes guys that are popular they hit
that number one spot and something
happens and there's some Marquee fight
that they're gonna make money off of him
so you get skipped and then they're like
well what is that guy gonna do I'm like
well here's the problem now the number
three guy goes out there and he gets a
win and now he might bump ahead of you
because you know what I mean like
especially gets like a big knockout yeah
so like I get like sometimes you gotta
stay busy even though you're there but
like O'Malley now because of his
popularity he doesn't have that problem
yeah like No One's Gonna jump over him
and he's also making money money outside
the Afghan so there's not a uh just
gonna jump in yeah if I'm Sugar's
manager I'm like we're not doing [ __ ]
then let's get it yeah I mean because
right now he's even making more as the
number one guy like milk that milk yeah
do your thing because I mean work on
your takedown defense you know and he's
with uh he's with garyvee for his like
his social media I think he negotiates
his own contracts yeah he doesn't have
an agent he negotiates his own contracts
and must've done a pretty good job
because when he was on food truck he was
like I see Dana tomorrow I'm going from
here to negotiate with Dana and I said
dude do you you don't have any
background business he said I didn't go
to college like they're sharks man like
you're dealing with sharks they're very
smart I'm telling you but make sure you
have all your ducks in a line like make
sure you're ready to go dude hopefully I
mean he has an attorney at least to
review them he has an attorney who give
a contract attorney please negotiate
himself he got a big deal contract but
now he's number one he wants to
renegotiate again that's where it could
get dicey because he's like no dude what
are you talking about we just made a
deal well they're they're gonna they're
gonna at least
start from a hard ball position like
they'll just go no you have a deal and
but he has tremendous leverage Frank who
did your negotiations when you're doing
do you have an agent manager yeah I mean
all the way from malki and and back you
know what I mean oh you were with the
first round yeah for about uh nine or
eleven you you want that like I remember
I was thinking about it you want a
division between yeah you don't want to
be the hurt your feelings like I
remember my manager you know I've always
pride myself
bro I told my agent I'm like called Joe
cell right now is when I was gonna fight
no Guerra and uh it started off good he
was I'm telling you don't hear this man
Josephine was brutal I'm like it's no
big deal he's like all right but don't
say anything like yeah don't ask pretend
I'm not in the car let me hear what it
how it goes it was the worst comment
those things you had those conversations
I've had with him because we were
friends for many many years he found you
yeah so I mean how many times ago eat
dinner with him and then my wife just
back and forth at one point I remember
sitting going dude I think I need a
Xanax or something before I eat dinner
with you guys like I need like I'm not
into that like medication but like any
insecurities you have oh oh dude it made
me [ __ ] what are you doing now Silva
just he retires
how long did it take you to shake that
conversation off like how many like for
real elections
it hurt my feelings so bad I literally
those are those conversations that
you'll sit and think about and you're
like and they still hurt you're like
yeah oh God that's why it was after I
knocked out kronkop and then they're
they're talking about the nogere fight
and then he's like we're giving shop a
gift here man this [ __ ] and he's like
this [ __ ] you know he can't knock out
no Guerra and we're gonna give it to him
in Denver he wants Brazil tell him to
shut the [ __ ] up just all you're like
what but the good thing that came out
and he's like in if you know we're
thinking if he gets past Sammy using
your Brock Lesnar I was like oh hell
yeah Brock me that's gonna be sick so
I'm I was hyped and but then it just
went really dark like any he was like
you know how about his fight with Roy
Nelson that that was a [ __ ] sleep
fast but that was a piece of [ __ ] like I
said you tell my teacher and you're like
that's my boss she's probably a piece of
[ __ ] yeah man am I we get off the phone
like somebody told you it's their job
I'm like I never want to hear that again
it was actually even more brutal for me
at times because we were friends so he
had to make sure that no one ever
thought I got favoritism so I actually
got it worse got worse yeah I got it
worse you're like oh your friends or
somebody discovered him it actually is
worse like I wish we weren't friends you
know I mean like like Joseph
was in Vegas discovered Frank yeah there
was two paths and one was like bad one
was worse I was getting the worst the
worst yeah I was like all right well we
got to err on the side of making sure no
one thinking yeah can I ask you guys who
was the um who is the uh six on tippy
toes
um
okay the guy uh Darvish is what's his
name that fought in the last card that
was camera no yeah I
that title shot he's won 10 in a row
right in a row yeah here's the problem
though the UFC you know their their
business model now you know they're
getting paid regardless Darius and I
love him I've known that guy's great the
problem with Darius is you know he gets
on the mic and he goes I'll fate 10 guys
if that takes to get a title shot and
Lord's My Savior and Jesus Christ and
he's like he's like Leave it to Beaver
but that's not an act he's real he's
been nice nothing wrong with Jesus bro
well you'll see he was a shape-shifter
by the way okay we'll get to that later
we'll get to that later zombie he was a
zombie I'll tell you what man so I'll
tell you what makes me not feel like a
zombie the best Kratom on the planet
let's call the Segway Sam I love the
best creative on the planet we're
talking about happy hippo it's my
Limitless pill I don't look like Bradley
Cooper but man I think like him when I'm
on the best crater on the planet the
best focused product I've ever used I
use before I do stand up any podcast
just hang out my family get through the
day Kratom is fantastic classic but
listen kratom's the wild west back in
the day like CBD you didn't know who to
trust you can trust my friends a Happy
Hippo if you like pills they got it
powders they got it gummies they got it
the shots the pink lemonade shot is my
favorite that's why I have like a
thousand of them in the uh cupboards
here I said cupboards like I'm an old
person listen it's fantastic Kratom is
good for you visit happyhippo.com use
promo code sick boy for 20 soft for life
that you can use that code as many times
as you want share it with your friends
you're woke Aunt your gay cousin it
doesn't matter visit happyhippo.com
promo code thick boy 20 off for life
especially World game get them to calm
the [ __ ] yeah dude wait you got shots
here what's up dog I got some Kratom
shots for oh yeah you guys like Kratom
French create them dude the one that you
gave me your Kratom looked awesome dude
I think that was Isis and actually it's
actually a liquid cream it's a
it's a cousin of a coffee plant and so
basically it has like it hits the same
receptors I think that like an opiate
would hit but without the side effects
so like where if you take a pain pillar
I mean obviously heroin has its side
effects right
um you know you stop breathing and you
die you know uh this one if you take too
much or you abused it you're gonna vomit
you're gonna get sick to your stomach I
mean so it's much healthier coffee yeah
let's think of coffee I mean if you
abuse coffee the way I describe it is
like coffee is to blow as Kratom is to
oxy yeah there you go it's not as
powerful but it scratches that itch if
you were like a heroin addict and you
wanted to get off it but like going cold
turkey and not feeling that anymore like
right for that yeah you could create
them there's a lot of people that have
that opiate addictions that use kratom
or if you're someone like me that like
oh you know listen I have a hard time
getting out of bed in the morning like
painkillers
guy that that this Cherry well the white
kratom's actually no energy they make it
talkative and they're energizing
don't taste great the way I do it some
people mix with juice
powder
your callum's doing a lot of that stuff
good I would like to do it but not for a
little while but I'm gonna go I'm gonna
my buddy's like I got like I think he
had like an Ayahuasca vape pen do they
have that I'm like why would you want to
do like any DMP or Ayahuasca off a vape
pen dude no I want to do it like wanna
suck a robot that's where the people
I want a shaman I want you know girls
with the real titties like
some National Geography I want the
tattoos on the face when I did when I
did the toad DMT I'm pretty sure it was
out of a vape actually with Mike Tyson
I did it with like a shaman and how'd it
go that's the one trying to give me do
this
it's like scratch yourself and you put
the toad poisoning no no like he smoked
it oh so vape pen bro it's like a yeah
it was like a or how do you know it's
real toad yeah oh [ __ ] I knew yeah
something right oh yeah what was your
take away from it oh dude I went into
outer space like the way that he
described it which is he's accurate
because he was like he's all he's like
you've done he's like you've done LSD
and shrooms I'm like yeah he's like so
that's you experiencing something he's
like this is gonna be like you
disappeared and you're all of a sudden
inside the Sun and I was like all right
that's like you just like that doesn't
sound like fun at all
are burning alive for 30 minutes it's
just like it just melts it just melts
your ego completely
oh yeah
yeah it's really good for trauma like
I've never done it either yeah
The Godly dose I guess it's six
milligrams oh yeah he was doing hard on
shrooms
yeah just one of the things he was in a
ball crying and you know the
it's all you know business likes like
set up in a safe room please like I was
farting uncontrollably like but I
actually never heard and the stuff he
was saying I was like oh how did they
not just
I'll tell you yeah DMT or or uh oh the
goddos room
s
yeah
he really is in the Bible always a
zombie yeah no he showed up as Jesus
Mary the apostles
look at those nipples bro they're going
into going into what is a psychedelics
look at the size of that guy
the guy behind him yeah
and like what's how tall is Jake
six six one something no 5 10. No 5 10
yeah but really I must be talking that
because I think I know scanners there's
no way no Jake has his shoes on there I
guarantee you Jake left his shoes on
Jake's myself jakey's my height I'm 5'10
yeah he's your height look at the girls
like their whole job is not to pay
attention just stare into the camera
now this is what I respect about the
Paul brothers so you see that bald head
guy behind them they all they're all
professional fighters for Titan FC yeah
shout out to Lex McMahon so Jake and
Logan all the security are like
professional MMA fighters oh wow all of
Floyd's because I remember Logan came up
to me because I worked his fight when he
fought Floyd he's like hey shop and he
had all security Rangers if my security
and Floyd Security on a fight who'd win
I'm like you'd destroy them dude these
guys are like champions in Titan those
are just big fat guys they can't fight
they're just there to like push and
shove people yeah you guys would arm bar
those big [ __ ] like really I'm like
yeah you do they're there to be a human
destroy them destroy their deterrence
you know yeah for for like regular
people MMA fighters go oh that's that's
candy yeah a big fat they can't move you
can't find I got him down a six one
that's what I thought I thought he was I
thought he's six months I mean it's
possible are you six five six four
Anderson Silva is definitely tall in six
one yeah yeah yeah so he Jake's not six
one that's the internet six one that's
like Hulk Hogan is he wearing platform
shoes when he's facing yeah no shoes on
there he's probably wearing big ass
earrings how about the guy from Barstool
who always takes pictures on his tippy
toes have you seen what is that yeah
okay Presidente oh oh uh
yeah do you look bigger yeah dude
speaking of people who have a great
[ __ ] sex tape that guy's his sex tape
is nothing to be embarrassed about at
all you guys see yeah one of morphine
you love sex tapes huh of course I
didn't know that existed man I mean I'll
I'll just at least I've watched porn in
Forever that's my new thing I'm giving
up yeah oh it's not fun anymore huh I
just like no drugs
oh I can't connect with any crowd that's
what I'm saying dude because you're
yanking back on the side yeah
k-o-k-o-k-o dude these guys are living
the life Bros Jake who was the original
Goldie what was his name from the UFC
they used to call him oh go Mike
Goldberg do you think you should be in
the UFC Hall of Fame yes yeah 100 do you
think they'll eventually do that
you would hope so do when you watch the
old ones like he was awesome like I I
still to this day prefer him and Rogan
and the old ones commentating oh no way
more than John annik and I mean they're
awesome it's a different time but it's
just different like it's like it's more
like Goldberg is awesome I love Goldberg
Goldberg's a buddy of mine but it's like
the content teams evolved now like DC
like you're talking about double champ
heavy yeah like and he's really good on
there and him and Brogan are friends so
there's a chemistry it's kind of like
FICA pain if you guys want my friends
you wouldn't be here the only reason
this thing works because we're friends
and there's a Vibe so a lot of people
when I talk about the Holocaust yeah I
dig that stuff because a lot of it I
haven't heard before I didn't know Jesus
was a campus or whatever you said yeah
or Cactus but it was just you know I I
think there's just a chemistry between
Anakin you know Eric just re-signed big
boy money I think just resigned for like
a long-term deal what do they do what do
they do for for one of these when
they're sitting on the you know when
they're on the desk what do you think
they do for a pay-per-view would they
pay those money yeah I know Rogan you
know the highest paid and hopefully
we're gonna be saying but I just know
because I know Comedy Works and I know
the amount of tickets he sells Rogan was
fighting so much when so let's say this
was a UFC pay-per-view tonight Rogan
loses money working for the UFC he he
makes more money doing stand-up if he
did one Arena he makes more money to do
in that Arena he takes a pay cut doing
UFC that's how much he loves the UFC but
he's got to be print money in those
Arenas too yeah and so so whatever how
many American pay-per-views they have I
don't know let's say 18 or whatever 12.
yeah so if he's working all 12 of those
those are 12 Arena dates he could have
done that's a Saturday night so that's
gone so he's actually losing money
because he loves UFC so and he does that
he does his shows around the office
because like when I was in Jacksonville
the night before and then and then he
was in Arizona also for 74.
those in the front row because they did
the show the night before the Asian dude
is [ __ ] hilarious funny good writer
great writer yeah great writer he's a
really great writer if he can turn his
Cliff's a Monster yeah they're all
hilarious if that guy could turn that
into uh storytelling he'll be one of the
best to do it so when you go in that
show they make you give your phone to it
yeah they should zip it up yeah of
course they can't have them
is Steve Burns so I was in San Jose and
I get a text from Delia goes hey man
Steve Burns hit me up you want to sell
him like and usually when people hit me
like they want something or whatever and
I don't know Steve at all I know him and
Brian work together and he's a comic
store guys yeah he's great I've seen
around the store so I don't know him
very well and I text Chris I'm like what
I'm busy bro like what you know what he
wants he's like it's Steve Burns he's
the best and I go all right I guess give
my numbers trust me he wants nothing
from me I'm like all right give my
number Steve texted me like hey he was
doing a theater with the guy from um
Impractical Jokers across the street and
he's are you staying at the same hotel
and like what hotels you the Hilton I'm
like I'm here see I'm saved the hotel
he's like let's just grab coffee I'm
like what the hell does this guy want I
couldn't because I was doing some other
Media stuff so then he's like you know
what I'll make it easy on you I finished
before y'all come to your late show I
was like all right in that time I'm like
what the hell's this guy want he comes a
late show I didn't know he was there and
then after I got off stage he comes to
the Green Room which is just like the
coolest guy he was like I just want to
see it for myself man I heard you
working hard he's like my god dude like
he was so cool I was like you don't want
anything he's like what he's correct
how's it going I'm an [ __ ] I figured
because everyone always when they do
that well they want so he's just a good
dude Steve and I were really close and
then he got mad at me because I uh stuck
my dick in his chicken sandwich then
watched him eat it and then he didn't he
got mad about that yeah it's so weird
Jesus how long ago was that
Sam do stand up of course Savage yeah
he's a 90s comic that has been canceled
he's the last of the last Mohicans you
can't got nothing to cancel
that's the thing about that it's like
dude if you if you're just like I'm not
playing you know like no matter what you
say they're just like no no you're like
[ __ ] you I think it will come back
around you know I think everything's
coming back around now that the
apparatus to cancel people isn't there
anymore that's how it goes right I mean
what CNN all these mainstream media are
dying nobody they have no way of
generating astroturfing this anger it's
all going well think about CNN's even
changed their platform right because
they got that new seat present or
whatever and he goes we're going back to
the news we're gonna quit doing this you
know just folks on the left hating on
the right they're going to do that
because people back in and then they
might turn but still at least he's
getting rid of people too see that's the
ours too man everyone's mad the D's
right now they're just gonna run
everybody over to the r exactly ours
will pull a bunch [ __ ] running on
everybody back to this guy you should
trust none of them yeah they're just
gonna switch the money
maybe like a Rand Paul who said some
credit maybe him but everybody else is
like I don't trust everything's local Go
Local do local local Politics the only
thing do you know what's crazy he's like
dude can you name the Republican
candidate that's running for governor
for for in the in this election that's a
week away in California
can you name the guy no nobody can does
anyone there's not a republican running
for mayor I could name him in Texas
where I live well there's a republican
Agora and he's very close to winning
which is affects my where in Agora like
calabasa yeah yeah yeah I mean like dude
there's not a Republican mayor candidate
for LA
recruit he's crazy
I thought it was Rick Caruso and then no
Elders Larry Elders was running for uh
during the recall yeah he's not running
this time Larry Elder's teeth bother me
but you don't like his teeth he's
Chompers dude he's got big teeth big
teeth I like chicken big teeth that's
why I brought it up fake and he likes
them cross-eyed he like he slightly
crossing
streets are hot I've never heard that he
wants some cross-eyed slightly dude not
like
just a little bit just one [ __ ] guy yeah
can you show me a picture example and
then just big old teeth yeah he likes
big chocolate it's my dick hard
yeah Larry Elders has some Chompers on
him dude I actually thought I had a
chance to win
oh we I mean dude you're gonna be in
Newsome here yeah I know
just so the record is anybody watching
this Gavin Newsom [ __ ] his chief of
staff's wife when he was the mayor oh
yeah and if you tweeted that you got
banned yeah but now now that dude when
he was running the guy up on stage said
he goes if if his best friend can't
dress up with his wife how do you treat
it yes
I was like get up yeah
because we're tribal animals like
there's certain like codes that men have
to have we work together it's like all
right it's kind of like the unspoken
rule that all of us know like you don't
bang each other's wives you about the
girls and like even like if it's an
ex-wife or next girl like you know you
start talking to someone's ex you're
like it's almost he's like oh [ __ ] you
did hey like are you like you like I
should probably go talk to him yeah at
the very at the least the very minimum
still like I still find it improppable I
mean first rule of Bro Club yeah yeah
you don't do [ __ ] my ex-girlfriends are
watching dude dude in the end because
like what does it say about you do it
all the time what does it say about a
person's character man he says they're
not a good person to me that's like a
scumbag move that's the least of my
words with Newsome but but it's like in
the NBA shows like the Boston Celtics to
keep Cleveland guys they're like let's
say the Cleveland Cavs right there's 30
chicks in the entire State you can't
bang you just can't bang them and they
still do it bro they still do they're
passing around wives or they're passing
around like groupies no they're banging
each other's wives and that's why with
the Boston Celtics this guy was banging
it not only is the vp's wife but I think
he looked up as a coach the coach the
coach yeah he's a good coach too the the
minority owners
wife he went after too dude are you nuts
bro that's the expression dude the ring
camera no yeah he like walked up didn't
realize how ring worked he's like hey
I'm here dick yeah he saw you ready to
get bottomed out and then the dude was
watching on ring he's like what the [ __ ]
is happening here not see the ring dude
I thought she was talking to him on his
phone that's why yeah I thought it was
the ring he like was like oh that your
dick deliveries here something like that
oh he had his dick in a box yeah he's
like yeah he's like here we are yeah
and I'll tell you about the guy lost his
job and good coach too yeah this
expression right like if like hey don't
shoot what you eat right hey talk about
talk about someone
yo there's all kinds of [ __ ] in the
world
there's probably like yeah you think
about it all right there's like probably
five that you shouldn't mess with
because it's career ending and like yes
and you hit two of the five you're gonna
be like doing the owners oh you're
you're an addict yeah you got problems
there might be a fetish for him like let
me [ __ ] someone's wife because I [ __ ]
ruin my life
yeah you got to ask him you're like is
there a girl on Earth that you wouldn't
[ __ ] because if that's not her then who
is and have you seen his wife dime piece
of course famous actress like super dime
oh yikes that's a wrap huh oh yeah y'all
game over yeah divorce movie embarrassed
yeah broke the rule the [ __ ] owner's
wife so like the next the next NBA hey
so who do what does she look like like
if I see it maybe I'm like all right
what is it are there any uh prop bets of
um
just Harrison Silvan I don't know we're
just throwing a head kick prop bets no
no no head kicks I think there was for
the McGregor fight right no there was
for that yeah there was that but there's
also Ben askren had a clause that they
wanted to set a contract going you know
if you do any takedowns any kicks like
you're gonna lose half your pay or
whatever well also two because I fought
on that card that was yeah that's a good
fight cutting that right we went the
distance and you you found the Ben
Astron yeah
it was a cruiserweight champion boxer uh
you had one arm no no that actually two
arms that one I went decision yeah I
lost a decision on that one but it was a
good box that's a good fight it's
competitive yeah but uh but they told me
as far as in Georgia the athletic
commission there they came in the back
and said hey if you foul your guy so
like if I have an overhook and I turn
and he goes ah and he can't continue to
fight you lose your whole purse oh wow
dude let me ask you now your whole purse
is gone no frankly they find the whole
thing yeah they're like so so because
like there's certain things like I
actually had a hard time with that when
I boxed is it like if you have an arm
you can't bend past 70 degrees like so
if I overhook you arm I can keep my arms
straight but if I put my thumb towards
my chest and I overhook you just an
instinct for you yeah and that's an
instinctive movement that's an Overlook
I've been doing it for 30 years
and like if I do this and you go ow
that's a foul I fouled you can't break
the 70 degree angle like Jon Jones
Global attack Sarah like he literally
broke his elbow doing that standing like
you can do it for frankly sure
yeah the Box doesn't realize but I also
get it from the commission like dude you
know how to do this stuff he does that
like let me ask you guys something no me
too I mean are you a black belt in Jiu
Jitsu no I've been taking no so prom a
girl though so like work for God bro
what did you guys think about that that
video where uh where Sean Strickland was
was sparring with Orlando Sanchez same
position that's what I was saying like
it's it's dirty it's dirty right no look
strickling be known as a hotter but he
was absolutely in the right foot yes he
was absolutely not wrong yeah you know
what I mean like I'll back him on that
one a hundred percent you know we're
rolling and you go and that's a
ballistic like I don't even have I'm
sure how do I say stop yeah
with that is I I didn't see the context
with how they're training before like
did he get he did they wouldn't even go
on sparring it was just live grappling
no gee grappling yeah and frowned upon
for sure
like almost like a tight face not really
a full undook and the
but have you ever had somebody do that
to you
uh no not never no one's ever done that
to me never yeah but also you you're
going to be and I've actually never done
that today but also you know especially
if I don't know the guy and it's uh
Orlando Sanchez is high level it's like
80cc Champion yeah yo dude monster so a
lot of that stuff it's like you got to
be ready to go p's and q's yeah but I
know that's like a that's like a like
it's a ballistic movement it's kind of
those things like you know there's
certain grappling moves it like it's
just like that's just you don't do move
you know what I mean like it's like you
slam a guy if he has a triangle yeah
lift me up and go hey dude let go like I
got you I mean like you know like give
the person opportunity you know what I
mean you know and the way he the way he
acted afterwards when Sean
kind of called him on it he was like oh
you're saying I'm in here I don't even
belong here it's like that was fresh in
your mind sounds like yeah that made it
yeah now that I remembered that detail I
had forgot about that oh that's what he
said he said that so I'm like okay so so
you did so it wasn't an accident you
were actually been going yeah I'm like
didn't fight you know what I mean like
if you're gonna like to me there's
certain times I'm like I'm crap if you
were to do that to me I'm like all right
dude look screw it let's fight you know
what I mean yeah
he's all hey man hey he's walking
forward it's like he wanted he was gonna
grab something yeah I like Orlando I
like Sean too that's tough yeah but that
was definitely and then Sean was getting
ready for a fight right yeah yeah that's
tough
yeah you know that it's like we're
fighting you know he's like I'm tapping
and you're ripping
Sean might have been [ __ ] with him a
lot in the gym though before I mean who
knows but I mean Sean's a tough
character yeah strictly definitely has a
certain you know you know there's a way
he gets hit him at all Frank yeah he
trained the long time of Syndicate and
stuff so I mean Sean when he walks in
the gym he has a mindset you know he's
like like you know his mindset like off
the bat like his default is to like kind
of be mean and then once you get down
that wall yeah 100 he really is a good
dude he's a really good dude but even
then like when he was when he trains he
trains hard but like he also doesn't
break the rules of training you know
what I mean like I've trained with him
he does Train's hard but there is no
like I've never had him kick me in the
knee have you ever been spawned together
and they throw spinning elbows or like
spinning uh back fists yeah everyone so
that's happening usually that's round
upon yeah or like jumping knees no no I
don't know if jumping he's too frowned
upon is it in training I suppose guys I
remember Pat Cummins was training with
verdum I went there to watch him and I
was like you know they're known
notorious known for going home to me
touch me with your knees unless you have
knee pads on like that's why I tell
people like if you want to throw hard
knees then put on knee pads like I like
to throw knees in practice but I wear a
big ass almost like hockey like yeah
so that way when I throw a knee and I'm
still not trying to break your ribs it's
sparring you know what I mean like we
still want the movement I'm gonna hit
you you know what I mean but like I'm
gonna practice the intensity because I
need a condition if I don't throw it
hard in practice then when I go to the
fight and I throw it hard I'm gonna get
tired you can throw me fast without it
being hard right yeah you're putting
away it'd be like like look a baseball
pitcher has to throw if he's gonna throw
100 miles an hour in the game he better
throw it 100 miles
all the time now not every day has to be
that but there's some times we go in
like we have those sparring days where
like you know look same even if they're
gonna spot like hey man you know Friday
we're gonna go hard okay hard means like
we're not going to talk to each other
before we Spar yeah if we come in we're
like just keep on your corner keep on my
corner
if I get rocked you know what I mean
don't finish yeah you know what I mean
like there's code you walk off but
you're also not my friend you don't sit
down hold me look walk to these neutral
corner and wait and then like then my
corner will help recover me if we think
I can continue sparring I'll continue
sparring if not if it's over with if
it's a bad enough concussion then spawns
over and now we can be friends again
it's been a good training partner yeah
there's a code and it's being
professional too like you know Shane and
I we just grew up Hard Knocks I remember
before Rothwell fight which even hit me
that hard but you know messed me up and
then even no Guerra a week before I flew
to Brazil we did that mock like fight
where we had a crowd there Shane's
getting my sparring partner Shane came
in he's at the lake he was like nine
beers deep came in late and I'm like
what are you doing let's go and my coach
like no no talking this once this as
real as we can first round Shane knocked
me out week before my fight I mean I I
came to him like what the AG what are
you doing dude the [ __ ] he's like I'm
so sorry brother I'm sorry he's just
he's just a big powerful dude what about
Anderson Silva they said got knocked out
see but they checked with Anderson's
thing I think that's him just trying to
to let the fans know how hard he's
trained for it yeah he didn't realize
saying I think he was saying I've had
rough sparring matches he didn't get
knocked out three times there's no way
English is new yeah so I think I'm
saying I think you said it I don't think
the English was much of a barrier but I
think what what Brenda say is 100 yeah
such dangerous guys that I'm getting
knocked out in practice you know what I
mean like but I'm not taking this easy I
wouldn't let those two chicks I'm like
well I hear what you're saying with them
what you're trying to convey but like
the company
like you're not supposed to be getting
knocked out you smell like cotton candy
days before I've been turning so hard I
have major brain damage yeah it's like
they're like yeah that's the Marcon
stuff came you know yeah and they're
like we can't We're Not Gonna Let You
fight because we're on the hook for him
he could he should he shouldn't have
been upset about that one dude like when
he said that was him that was dumb UFC's
like he tied their hands yeah you know
TJ dillashawn's out a year he's having
uh his fourth surgery on that shoulder
yeah you heard it turned out that like
that thing had been sliding in and out
every day I think I saw anything like 20
times a problem but to defend TJ he was
like but I was able to still could train
go through the rounds and it would fall
out and push it back in he's like and
then as we got close fight got way worse
not a fight it was the worst it's ever
been and he's like you know I I wouldn't
selling wolf tickets he's like I wasn't
trying to you know one up anyone just
get a Payday he's like a little legit
thought I could beat him with my messed
up shoulder yeah 100 what I thought when
I had one arm in my last fight but
honestly like when I signed it it was
bad by like five days before the fight
it was like I have no arm and then in my
mind I'm like you know what it's a
grappling match with boxing I can
wrestle I'm gonna pull on his head I can
lift my arm I'll I'll figure out a way
to win them and they said Frank no
grandma yeah then I'm in the locker room
they're like okay no this is just a
boxing match with them at May gloves I'm
like oh it's just terrible yeah this is
terrible that's what Matt said Matt said
when they told me he's like wait what
yeah no spinning back Knuckles because
you can't punch
wait a minute yeah but Matt said they
came well that's what they sold us all
what am I supposed to do argue like hey
okay well then don't walk out don't get
paid like what are you gonna do yeah I'm
literally hands wrapped already been
through the commission right and then
you're hearing that I'm like dude I'm
fighting in 30 minutes and you're
telling me now that this is uh you
basically get a bare knuckle box yeah
yeah those gloves they're not with one
arm yeah yeah with one arm which I still
if I would have had the rules of
actually I could hold you and punch at
the same time I would still bet on that
yeah I felt extremely confident and
screwed and then also just even if he
didn't get what his shoulder prop just
the the the him not being used to that
his shoulders oh yeah it feels like a
wrestle for two minutes they wrestle for
two minutes and throw a punch yeah it's
not easy unless you've trained it and
yeah he's not used to it no would you
let them fart on you here's my thing Sam
and then then what after that it was
just well I mean that's the entry fee
yeah sure I don't know that one on the
left looks like an actual robot like in
my face yeah oh look at Jake dude man
yeah Jake's about like this this is the
craziest thing for me about Joe hold on
real quick real quick is he doing the
Wilder is he wearing a weighted vest
into the ring that's frowned upon yeah
right because while they're using as an
excuse yeah right afterwards he goes
that that suit was over 80 pounds he
yeah he accused his trainer of poisoning
his water at one point after that yeah
like a mental after for a while he's
freaking out because I mean you when
you've knocked out every guy you've ever
faced yeah I mean like I think like
sometimes like I mean at that point 40
guys get fought you know I mean and the
first guy that even made it without him
knocking out was remain stivern was a
guy I was a sparring partner with and
man he starched him that second second
yeah it was a meme him just sliding yeah
I know of course yeah
but he remains a good dude yeah yeah
he's a super good guy yeah he like
brings a lot of guys in the gym and
trains him and brings up lots of bummer
you know what like he's not just like
you know most of the guys you see in the
in the boxing gym like they're out for
themselves you know I mean they're
different MMA yeah mma's like a brother
he's actually more like that he's almost
like that's why I got along with him so
well he's more like an MMA fighter than
mine said yeah he has a lot of young and
up and coming guys after he's done with
his spawn he jumps in there and spars
them and he's coaching helping them yeah
man he's the only boxer I've seen and
there might be more I'm not saying in my
experience yeah that he he doesn't let
me ask you guys this for this Main Event
kicks off Jake Paul and so it's about to
go down right now they're introducing
him uh the girl that Sam didn't like
with the tummies out of there so they
lit they're listening they're listening
these guys commenting but uh who has
more pressure on them Anderson Silva or
Jake Paul Jake Paul Jake first time I
say Anderson I see Anderson you get
knocked out by a YouTuber Disney kid
yeah yeah but you're yeah
no one thinks that dude we don't care no
he doesn't know he doesn't look that way
but also he's not taking it he's not
going I'm 46 this young pumpkin yeah
he's like I can't he still thinks like
in a box hell no yeah but okay if he
loses he might end up moving to Iowa
like Wyoming in a cabin like that dude
with a beard that hides up there in the
mountain who's that guy like oh that
used to be Anderson Silvia Brazilian he
went into hiding Jake Paul
guy that's trying to get away from his
career what is this question loses yeah
I mean no no oh my God
no if if he starches him like that that
would be insane if he starches him the
now the narrative I guarantee you online
they're gonna go well he knocked that
old guy they're not going crazy
well if he gets starched it's gonna be a
tough road for him but if he if he loses
my decision or he he gets knocked down
gets back if he goes he's gonna be okay
it's the best he's gonna go okay you
guys are saying like like the stakes
to them like Anderson was like dude if I
[ __ ] lose this fight then everybody
knows I lost Jake Paul if Jake Paul's
like I lost Anderson Silva It's Anderson
yeah Jake Paul's not gonna go to the
locker room if he gets knocked out by
him some people are not gonna look at
him like dude you got knocked out
because the end of the day trust me yeah
it's gonna be very quiet and Anderson's
still like he's just sit there and like
like people are gonna have a hard time
with it like the people around him and
like going home and he's gonna have a
hard time with it he and you know he's
fought Woodley Woodley was a tough test
for me past that New Hampshire was a
different different level you're like
Amsterdam box box yeah and I do think
and I do Tyrone Woodley's a lot smaller
you know I agree yeah and and I and
Woodley's a safer fight like this isn't
a safe fight for him that's why I
respect him so much because he's putting
everything on the line but I do think
Jake's gonna be a little surprised I
know he's boxing with really good boxers
and that credit to him kudos to him and
he spars hard trains hard Anderson just
his technique he's even get up on him
it's hard guys Anderson does hit hard
especially coming forward yeah yeah
which is what you have he throws so
loose in real relax and he hasn't lost
and look 46 he hits as hard as he hit
when he was 26. yeah you're not losing
power's last thing yeah it's the last
thing to go so trust me as hard as he's
ever hit he still hits that hard and he
I've seen him start guys with Jabs yeah
me too I mean he's doing people's faces
he's either go
do you think he's to go he's up there
nah Jon Jones to me he's the goat dude I
mean no argument either I think John's
number one but Anderson should be in
this discussion of the top three like
everyone talks about khabib John and
Mighty Mouse yeah Demetrius yeah but how
you don't have Anderson in there and
everyone goes PD is what it's like dude
they say ped's by Anderson yeah he got
busted I know he did but like but you
know
here we go now I I do think Jake it's
gonna take a little while unless you
just land something crazy but I think
he's being surprised how elusive
Anderson is he's gonna get down on the
cards he's moving forward who's moving
backwards is going to take a round and
just and see what he's got now Sam did
you see him versus Julio Chavez uh
junior I watched a little I mean you
watch that like this dude can box
his combos his body works well he wants
to fight Roy Jones back in the day Dana
to Boston that was and that was at that
point in Jones's career that would have
been a bad idea
yeah no same thing and that's what Dana
said he goes That's a terrible fight
dude that's why I like Francis fight one
of the greatest boxers it's still a
great boxer you know I mean the best on
the planet yeah I think he's best I
think he's best everywhere all the time
dude this guy Jake Paul I agree four
years ago yeah yeah I don't I mean if
you put all the things in the prime you
can do everything I think Tyson Fury
beats them all oh yeah he'll be he'll be
yeah he's good at it I saw that I saw
that the while him versus Wilder first
fight I was there oh you're there in the
center it was crazy bro where he popped
up like The Undertaker yeah
I was like oh he's got this the only way
he loses
is if he gets knocked out bam he gets
knocked down I'm like oh my God see
Anderson's just kind of downloading
seeing what this kid's about so Jake's
throwing a lot but Anderson didn't get
going there
look at look at Logan can you imagine
how Logan Paul's feeling right now your
brother's fighting Anderson Sylvia has
five fights and you guys were on YouTube
and Disney that's what I'm saying dude
like four or five years ago where Jake
Paul was that's why I have so much
respect for these guys it's like this
shit's impossible what he's doing like
him him it'll never happen again look at
his mom started Tyron Woodley like
that's what I always talk about on the
channel it's like dude
if you would have said four years ago
where they were like hey there is a
world where this kid knocks out this
dude you could I would literally like
you could castrate me if that fun fact I
would have bet the same exactly black
and white is a cult uh occult colors
just fun facts black and white it's also
a delicious cookie yeah it is it is that
the half moon yeah cookie bro
I knew you'd like that
yeah Jay cuts a bunch of more ink huh
a lot of guys do that especially in
Hollywood a lot oh that's dicey oh look
at Jake he said come on Jake's game dude
is a young man good thing is in shape
because he's burning a lot more energy
yeah just his demeanor if we were to
measure his heart rate if we had a
measure oh it's like 20 yeah 30. well
probably 145. Anderson's right now
Anderson is 115. yeah and I think
Anderson knows maybe his advantages
later in the rounds with the experience
in conservative energy because Jake
beans got slower towards the end of the
first Iron fight but agreed but the the
point there it's like you put a famous
makes one mistake Jake's young where
that power is still it's there in the
eighth round for sure
yeah give Jake that first round which I
thought Jake would lose the first round
but Anson no I would have told I I never
thought I just would win the first one
unless he knocked him out yeah yeah
Anderson just his two calculated he's
done that yeah he's downloading he's
like all right let's see what he's like
and I'm sure this place safe he's a
young powerful yeah let me not extend
myself let's go ahead and use you know
technique to win I mean I think it'd be
more I mean obviously a knockout
everyone's gonna be talking about it's
online I think it would be more
impressive if Jake beats him via
decision that would be if you beat him
eight rounds to zero yeah like outbox to
Anderson Silva yeah yeah oh
hit him
nice slip Anderson Silva oh dude he's a
magician dude
I was saying too like
most he took it very seriously I'm very
confident right now with Anderson's
fighting oh Anderson's that's it yeah
look at him
yeah yeah he's ready to go he's not
taking this attention still but there's
no way he would risk his legacy on
getting knocked out by a YouTuber not be
ready to go he just loves to fight you
know but he loves the technician too
he's a master man
uh when action starts increasing like if
you want your Hulu Shabbos see the
similar thing and then once he gets
going he's throwing combos it's a real
problem
uh I'll tell you the other problem is
Tim is this the first time Paul's face
to Southpaw in a fight
yeah yeah that's a good point I mean
unless basket is but that wouldn't like
matter
oh oh wow Anderson's getting aggressive
yeah that was an uncharacteristic punch
for Anderson
oh wow Anderson's moving too yeah now
he's starting to move Jensen put it on
yeah but that movement's gonna make burn
a lot of energy on Anderson now he likes
that loose oh oh Anderson's trying to
get him out of there now to to fear to
answer his credit with his legacy with
his legacy he needs to mop the floor
needs to mop the floor with him he's
like dude I'm on the greatest of all
time you have five fights dude so the
anders oh oh
see now he's talking now he's popping
him he's being the big dad all right
come on oh [ __ ] we gotta fight on our
hands boys
Anderson's [ __ ] yeah
ready to go like there's a scary 5 10.
look at Anderson I thought Jake was a
lot bigger than that
well he won the first part of that round
now he's gonna take off the middle part
of the round relax and then win the last
part of the round he was Pro dude you
think how much experience he has at the
highest level
uh he lift his leg I think he that was a
Michael Jackson
oh look at him
oh
he rolled with it he rolled with it yeah
now that hook line is trouble oh look at
himself oh and he was standing Orthodox
Anderson's a showman too though now yeah
yeah
the first loss he had against uh Weidman
yeah
oh where's like oh look at him go dude
dude he's 47 I can't move like that at
38.9
how old are you I am uh 21. I'm 21 years
old
I don't think Jake can go I've had a
roughness I don't think so either I
think just you see how Jake's moving
just him trying to avoid this onslaught
of answering is tiring Jake out yeah
that's his plan that shot that Anderson
I mean he still has five oh man dude I
don't think I've ever seen him throw a
bunch Anderson
the company he's not letting go Jake's
breathing hard and Ash is not being
friendly you've seen him push him off
like he's like hey [ __ ] oh oh there we
go Jake's not come on I like the bot I
like the body and then go up top Jakey
this almost looks like a y fight too
like oh like at the Y during the
basketball game
damn what YMCA do you go to dude
[Laughter]
oh look at the Anderson's messing around
yeah that scares me though I hate that
stuff yeah but again what I do like is
Anderson's pretty serious too oh yeah
seriously Anderson yeah oh yeah it's 1-1
look at this uppercut whoa those are two
flush shots now I'm the sixth and
seventh and eighth round Jake's not
gonna be able to take them I want to see
that one that Jake hit him with those
eyes are big right now damn he's like oh
[ __ ] this guy can bike yeah he's like oh
yeah Bubba
he did some river dancing that right
there how close he was relaxed I hate
when he died this one see like no no he
missed he rolled it with the shoulder
look brought the elbow up roll the
shoulder turn this yeah now this this is
what bothers me now this is just a Jake
Paul thing you know they're young but
notice how many people are watching the
fight through their cell phone it's like
dude you're at the event oh dude quit
looking through your phone screen
metaverse well here let me school you
guys a little bit from what it's like to
be in the crowd sometimes you can't see
[ __ ] from the crowd sometimes like you
end up watching it on the screen yeah oh
I hate life I did stand up
Awards people who videotape fireworks
you guys are never gonna watch this it's
true yeah you can get that on you no no
it's triggering also if let's say Frank
you text my dude check out the fireworks
with my family I would never talk to you
also there's two things
fireworks people that film The
Zoo oh
he's like what's interesting complaining
who's the who's the MMA fighter not
oh
I don't like it when he switches
Orthodox he opens it up for that right
hand over the top of the shoulder but I
know he slipped the one but I mean
right now he really makes Jake's right
hand far away I'll tell you I love his
approach of putting Jake on his back
foot because he hasn't really had to
fight like this yeah this is a intensity
of Jake's not had to do yeah in uh with
the lights well not with the lights on
you know what I mean like I'm sure in
training oh those are all arm punches
now he's not even throwing proper body
shots Anderson could see he's like Jake
Paul's used to throw in at stationary
objects it's like he's like oh yeah no
no I don't think yeah I don't think uh
Nate Diaz would apply the same volume
but this would be very soon
it would be similar like like Nate would
provide the same kind of volume like the
the pressure maybe not the same
quickness of the Anderson but it's there
that was a good punch by Jake dude
honestly oh [ __ ] if if Anderson wins
this fight
I will actually have Anderson there's
less Anderson gets knocked out like he's
won this fight yes yeah but like from
what I've seen right now like there's
nothing oh nope and look he's not even
stunned oh there we go
like Jake Jake's tired
and he got caught with a right hook
coming in Jake sweenum ah Jake might get
knocked out
right here she's a real Savage you know
what I think he should though if you go
out on your Shield man you know what I
mean because right now you can get
outclass ready yeah don't hold back and
just lose a decision oh you can get beat
up go ahead man let loose and go for the
home run I agree I agree does he have
tattoo the kids don't think like us
though Frank do you know
it's my best
his dad's the bald guy uh so his mom's
on the left next to the bald guy right
there look it's like looking CK if Lucy
K was on trt he looks like Kim oh that's
his and way over there yeah that's his
mom had the fist up yeah
oh
I mean Jake will go at heart it's still
only the third round like but he's uh if
you're Jake and you're like what round
am I in am I in seven they're like no
[ __ ] oh [ __ ]
he's swinging hard those are all going
to be but there's also levels to the
like some of this is
again as a with my background I'm so
much kinda as much as I and Jake no I
love the [ __ ] of Jacob I like
Anderson too oh I think he's grateful
this is still not honestly if he gets
knocked out right now like he's still
hey man he's a winner in my book agree
he trains harder yeah is Anderson's nose
problem he took a bad shot
but there's also something to it too
right with a guy with Finance Silva
who's I mean one of the best or do it no
this part of he's like that's how this
should go it's gangster the part of it's
kind of how it should go right
yeah you know part of me is like yeah
this is a good fight man I know it's
entertaining you could say I mean
everyone's complaining about the action
in in his last fights this is a great
fight that no matter who wins it's like
the Woodley fight some slow rounds this
was yeah much better fight and
Anderson's bringing it dude yeah and
again like if Anderson wins
that means there's no question that this
was just like a completely legit fight
and that means Jake Paul actually was
like I'm gonna train and try to fight
Anderson Silva and he's been bananas but
Ben Astron said the best thing
oh Ben Astron said the best thing he was
all his body that was the best were fake
stuff like that he goes you know how
stupid that is he goes of course I want
to beat him he was if I beat Jake he
goes why would I why would I give in let
him knock me he goes if I beat Jake then
I'm fighting his brother then I'm
fighting Conor I'd make so much [ __ ]
money I would never take a fall he's
like there's so much more money in
beating Jake than losing to him he's
like that's so stupid
dude his nose bleeding yeah yeah oh
there you go Jakey
good for Jake Paul man dude which which
shot hit his nose
yeah
he put his whole body behind that one
too yeah and to be honest I thought that
would have got an instant out of there
because you know I thought maybe it was
the miles on Anderson but he's right
there no didn't even Buckle him at all
oh
buddy you got you gotta you gotta tune
it up you gotta set it up
his nose broken dude but how great is it
for uh Jake Paul just for other fighters
to learn like you see everything says
MVP most valuable Productions that's all
Jake's production yeah like it's his
thing man oh really he owns that what I
see I I wasn't sure I felt like I
thought he had something going on with
triller like in the the former CFO with
UFC that's not right uh the the former
CFO the UFC's his Mansion like business
and he's has something to do with
trailer uh I think back in the day but
now it's all like Showtime this is a MVP
production with Showtime but MVP's
Jake's business good for him dude and
Jake has the sport show and he has his
podcast now he's making well Jake gets
his most power from throwing with his
head right so he throws his body he's
there right there says come forward
so as long as Anderson keeps moving
forward he's going to keep jamming
Jake's winning this round no he's not oh
I don't think so no I don't know he's
got caught with three hard shots yeah he
he'll throw the three bombs but
Anderson's and he's missed with all
those bombs yeah
has he landed a hard shot this one
yeah he did he landed he landed a couple
oh but you you'll notice uh Anderson's
investing it's like a bank investor he's
Landing these little shots when Jake
comes in that people aren't giving him
credit for I think
so apparently the crowd's chanting Silva
and they booed uh Jake when he walked in
that's how it goes that's all right yeah
it's Anderson Silva dude he's a legend
I mean if Jake wanted to get Applause
the kid doesn't know in Ohio his
hometown which was where he fought uh
Woodley at but
I think he wants this pressure man yeah
he's a wild boy look at his hair he's
one of those guys that really well he
wasn't in love he doesn't care and now
he's just checking off bucket list
that's why I give him him and Logan
respect
they have such uh a following they could
play chess he doesn't have to be doing
it they don't have to be doing this is
the worst cake in the world Frank come
on here
they make so much [ __ ] money
on YouTube and they can do this now let
me ask you this Jesse if Anderson uh
beats uh Jake do we get answered Nate
boxing because if Jake loses I doubt
Nate's gonna fight him
um do you get Anderson oh I think I
think honestly I think if Jake loses it
makes more sense to fight Nate yeah
because I think if he beats Anderson
then it's kind of weird to fight me I'm
gonna give that one like uh honestly I'm
giving that to Jake I know we're leaving
the way it finished right there with the
uppercut popping his head back look at
Logan dude I love watching Brothers
watch their brothers compete like my
favorite moment in NFL history is when
uh symmetrical that's chicks faces
Eli Manning threw the touchdown the
Super Bowl and they showed the clip of
Peyton up in the thing and he lost his
mind I love that yeah Jake's level girls
don't have to fart in his face to have a
hard time you know no you get the fart
in their face exactly
and you're not playing Jacksonville
Jake's girl is a dime piece though
go samtripley.com check out my YouTube
channel youtube.com
uh I'm in Kansas City second week in
November that's right hand you say
Kansas Kansas City improv no I I do the
comedy club oh nice I love that place
yeah throat
whoo man I tell you Jake's already one
you know oh yeah I know I'm not he's
yeah I think his status is still his uh
what am I trying to say I mean it's a
weird comparison it's kind of like sugar
Peter Exactly I was thinking of the same
thing everyone's like he's over hyped
there's one you know he's famous for no
reason and they see like against Peter
John I mean no way you can watch sugar P
John go oh he's not an elite fighter
there's no it's impossible oh good body
shot oh
the fact the fact that he broke into
Silva's nose you won yeah yeah dude
that's impossible to do starts Tyron
Woodley and then broke Anderson Silva's
nose
and he's doing well this round those
jobs are an issue for Jake he hates
being jabbed like they say he's still oh
he's going Philly's shell
Anderson
so Steve farhood oh look they got they
got Paul up uh yeah and uh Steve Harvey
is usually I mean he's been around
boxing about a hundred thousand years
he's such a smart dude
that's why I wouldn't bet on on Anderson
is because I knew like oh yeah
sorry what am I saying second round the
third either two two
yeah Oh I thought it was 2-2 but I don't
know what do I know
but yeah I mean if it goes to the
decision you gotta figure
so just you're gonna give it to Jay
you're saying yeah 100 yeah yeah because
there's a future there yeah
um so Jesse you're saying if Jake loses
then the Nate Diaz fight makes more
sense yeah see I think he beats him like
his that profile goes up even higher
Nate's gonna want to fight him anyway
because Daniel was saying Nate thinks
it's the circus so he's like I don't
want to fight that guy that's not real
like you know his whole yeah kind of you
know the way he portrays himself is I'm
this gangster I'm about real fighting he
doesn't think this is real but I bet you
see those dollar signs you don't think
he's real dude I can see it both ways
actually yeah I mean like Anson Nate
would be fun
wait what'd you say Sam I I was like is
it is it normally at this level of
Jake's career like the amount of fights
he has is it normally eight rounds or is
that yeah I think because he only has
five fights here here's here's right
still before some guys yeah some guys
before like the undercard was four but
um this way you could give Jake respect
because in boxing you guys are usually
when they're like 5-0 even 10 in some
cases they're fighting cams yeah they're
just
rolling twelve yeah the Woodley is a way
tougher fight with three fights four
fights that's a nightmare yeah you won't
get incredible I know they're not boxers
but they are what they are uh maze
caught him about five times they're at
least tougher than anything Canelo
fought in his first 10 facts oh dude
they just they fight so no doubt in
anybody's mind that he's winning this
round this round right Sam right you
don't think he's conspiracy do you
foreign
like sub five minute mile first round he
throws in it I just messed up and I was
going for an over and under and I just
let his hand go and you know it's croak
cop and he's like oh cool story dude
check this out how about I give you a
Croatian nose job I didn't think
anything of it just small slight elbow
shattered my entire nose and I remember
I you can't breathe no and I was like
and not only getting up with your nose
but you know it's blood and now it's
tasting all the blood tastes just like
nickels in your mouth yeah and then I
was like why am I so tired I got red
wings so I know that yeah yeah getting
hit in the nose makes you not want to
fight no I was just like why am I tired
this doesn't make sense and then my
coach like your nose is broke dude I was
like oh [ __ ] there she is that's my girl
single mothers no they didn't show the
the tell me that's okay dude they were
listening
I move needles bro yeah
she was pretending to be part cross-eyed
as Chris says you provide a bomb
yeah these next two rounds will be
interesting well three six seven eight
yeah
yeah dude hats off the if Jake wins by
decision
now the nearest gonna be like it's fixed
it's a real blah blah blah but this is a
great fight man yeah
this is the two best actors in the world
who's the showrunner
anybody who talks [ __ ] about Jake after
this is a just how about like Stone
haters how about Jake's dad's mom look
at her she like she she's into it dude
Jake Jake's Dad's girlfriend oh the dad
gets more nervous than anything that
Logan asked me to talk to his dad before
his fight against Floyd I went through
his dad Hey listen dude I don't know you
but uh your son is fighting a 147 pounds
yeah worst case he gets dropped with the
body he's that he's gonna be fine your
son's so much bigger you're lucky he's
not fighting like a Deontay Wilder oh my
God
we might legitimately die yeah your dad
was like right right I feel not so great
about it yeah he's in danger of
potentially getting tired and being
uncomfortable you get slapped around
that's why I told him I was like he
might get beat up and out class but he's
gonna be fine
it's not easy to get starchy okay man
yeah silver won that last round
yeah I remember we have it three two
Silva
when Logan was gonna fight him when
everybody was doing all these breakdown
videos everybody had Mayweather by
knockout I was all what the [ __ ] are you
guys talking about the [ __ ] is he gonna
knock it out unless Logan gets tired 24
year old Floyd Floyd Mayweather doesn't
knock people exactly Floyd doesn't shout
out guys his own size unless you're a
weird actor in Japan or whatever that
was weird or whatever
yeah
that that most recent one was good dude
yeah that was really good
the rising guy dude that guy was trying
to decade yeah Floyd knocked him out
yeah that one was good dude
I think Jake might be winning this one
too maybe yeah it's close
he landed that was a good combos early
on now now well he's Landing well I mean
like if let's say Anderson Silva takes
this oh
then then we have a Thai fight in the in
whoever if it's close if it's close and
listen for the sport of boxing and I
agree with this you got to lean towards
Jake Paul because there's a future
like maybe you know this is great yeah
he's not winning
it just depends if Jake wins it depends
on like where he wants to take his
career if he wants to keep doing circus
fights then then you know you do Nate if
you want if you want
to take a real rank is tired dude I
would probably give an answer to that
last round yeah yeah he closed it out
too close out because it was kind of
close I don't know and then I mean those
shots at the end who's that who's that
crazy bro all right yeah that's the dude
that yeah yeah the former head oh that
could have been a lot worse
yeah ever since not a spring chicken
's pointing to the Head how old is uh is
Cesar Chavez the one that Anderson beat
season must be late 20s
the one that Anderson beat yeah so maybe
maybe you do maybe do Jake maybe 36 now
okay not young yeah so maybe you have
Jake fight him after if he beats
Anderson that would be a tough fight I
think that's a step back if he beats
Anderson but it's a but it's a step into
like I'm fighting real boxers but he
beat Chavez yeah
the knock on there they're like well
Chavez Jr didn't train for it he didn't
take it serious wow they said he barely
trained that's the rumors Chavez uh
Chavez Jr versus Anderson they're like
Chavez didn't care he barely trained
I bet you Chavez wouldn't train for Jake
either which might not be a bad fight
for him
yeah he's one of the only as he kicked
out a wild card Freddie was like I can't
work with you you're not disciplined
enough Caesar Caesar Chavez Jr yeah
Freddie kicked him off the team
stop working with them
I mean look at it look at his eyes
yeah I mean when your dad's the greatest
Mexican box of all time oh they gave
that one to Paul of course oh man
fatherhood knows his [ __ ] too but I
think he's off on that but Farhad knows
way more about box than I do
what do you think Frank who do you think
got six I gave it to Anderson yeah
yeah I would like to see the punch count
okay
I wish I had showed the punch count
between rounds yeah good mom is the best
do Khalil Roundtree want to fight today
against uh oh did he beat uh dude
me too Khalil school it's Mark and
that's and khalil's with Markel too and
but like dude the other guy landed like
70 more strikes than him dude it was
really like it's a really crazy decision
oh it was a decision
no oh Khalil won the third round
I mean the strikes were
outlandishly in the other direction
where it was like everyone's all whoa
dude I'm just glad Cleo Anthony
Anthony's at the ESPN desk and he even
texts me he's like what the [ __ ] really
yeah it was uh at least Cleo one though
yeah
oh well
that's not Paul winning this round so
far yes dude think how hard
for this fight I mean this has been a
taxing fight on him
he was really tired in that second round
and like he's not tired but like you
could tell his body went oh [ __ ] he was
missing punches the the the pace was
something new I bet you just look at
their faces he has a lot of heart I have
a great chin too I mean is there a fight
going on in the crowd
somebody's staring at something someone
said something ideas
oh oh that was a pretty nice lead right
yeah
yeah his head movement's good too after
the punch unless he sticks way better
good shape when he sits against the
ropes because you know it's not crazy
stuff it's this winds judge is over and
Jake's having a success when he's in the
when he's in the middle of the room get
back to the center of the Ring he's had
much more success in the center ring
yeah against the ropes he's losing yeah
that's also what Anson did to Chavez Jr
against ropes just teed off on him
Chavez didn't have the cardio so just
set against the ropes lost rounds yeah
uh have you noticed Jake's girls in
black and white too yeah a dog that's
why I said and his mom wait what's the
black and white thing about cult occult
everything's a call to Sam it's all cold
sounds like you know bloody nose is a
flat Earth everyone has to go to Paul
huh which day not around yeah yeah
boom
boom
upstairs
that's a good combo right there that's
pretty Mike Tyson's Punch-Out Vibes too
low one high
hahaha
I hate when Jake's against the ropes
that's a good entry punch there too from
Jake that's nothing dude there's a clip
of Tyson everyone on their phones a clip
of Tyson on the heavy bag when he was
like 19 or 18 where he does that that
like goes three to the body
left left right here he goes yeah and
like it's you watch it you're like
that's [ __ ] insane that a person can
move that vest and even in myths Now You
See It Like Jesus yeah you know what's
weird
Alchemy never could drop down to like a
lower weight class carries a lot of you
don't need to but when he started when
when the heavyweight suddenly exploded
to six seven right and he was still five
whatever he is there wasn't really a
time in his career where like the the
size was you know like well Riddick bow
right here we go around oh [ __ ]
Anderson's coming son in the fight's so
close oh
get off the ropes Jakey get off the
ropes Anderson no Anderson's like I
gotta finish this [ __ ] kid oh [ __ ]
[Music]
oh nice late round he's gonna drop he's
rocked Daddy was right
now that's a fight yeah
that's my thing like Anderson I told you
in the outclass some technical and
volume but Jake has the power and now
this gives Jake energy well not and
Harrison's Taking Chances oh holy [ __ ]
chance this is nuts dude if he finishes
them here
Wow Come on Jake well Anderson's gonna
have to take chances if he takes chances
he's gonna get knocked out yeah he's
gonna get knocked out but Anson's being
pretty concentrated he's probably still
a little cobwebs up there okay maybe not
get out of there
God damn it I mean he's won the round
look at Anderson's face man
dude
[ __ ] career you knocked and silver
flat on his ass yeah dude I'm I'm saying
dude nobody gets a tattoo his new tattoo
Anderson on his neck flat unsurf on the
canvas like now when Jake says he's
gonna do something I don't care how
[ __ ] crazy it is I'm gonna be like I
don't know man because honestly I
thought this was too much to chew on me
too I had an Anderson to win oh [ __ ] get
out oh
I mean this is [ __ ] crazy dude
I I just think if Nate Diaz is next and
you're coming off a win over Anderson
that's nuts dude that is because now
even haters of Jake are gonna buy his
next paper oh yeah and you beat Anderson
Silva now for knocking him down there's
no
there's really no argument they could
promote the [ __ ] out of it you're right
Silva go from here back to Brazil yeah
he lives in Redondo but still he does
yeah he has a school out there takes his
check in Torrance
wow he knocked him down dude done a big
shot he Anderson needed the knockdown
yeah big time Anson's exhausted
he said I just do a high kick bro
just one yeah I'd be like [ __ ] my purse
check out the sidekick dude John danaher
always says like uh that any person
given five years if they dedicate
everything they have into anything they
can compete with world-class people I
think John's wrong on that yeah I think
so a little crazy I mean look
uh Jake has a lot of attributes that
with his athleticism oh okay you know
not really not anyone not anything yeah
anyone's Bridge he's not pay for
everything good like there's a lot of
comics where like you know 10 years
you've been 10 years to play golf ball
one there's a lot of comics you probably
shouldn't be doing because they've been
doing so long it's all they know and
they're not selling tickets but they
have some like you know yeah
Gatekeepers yeah I might have been
misquoting him that was nuts yeah I lost
my voice bananas I can't believe it
because obviously too like just his body
mannerisms and posture I'm like you look
like a boxer yeah
and what I was to say is that like he
looked like he was having like I mean
there was a point where he had to dig
deep mentally you and I were talking he
looked tired in the third yeah in the
third round he was like oh damn I
haven't felt this before I haven't hit
somebody and I'm still in a fight he was
just like this is the first fight he's
been that's what I'm saying like we
learned and he really now Harrison the
fighter right we don't know
you've got a highlights like Jake
tonight we learned so much him going to
beat him via decision knocking him down
and nuts and people were like I bet he
won't take on Anderson he was like [ __ ]
you he did and then there's no he can
watch that fine go oh it was rigged yeah
no no way ever since I was going to take
a fall Year boy like have a great fight
but to win the fight yeah it's like
double double dude here's what else is
pretty dope too right usually Jake with
you know the Floyd stuff the Conor Nate
especially he talks all this trash and
gets a little you know whatever this he
was pretty respectful and I'm sure it's
still sold well and he beat him you know
so you don't have to do that weird like
youngster Tick Tock talking [ __ ] all the
time being mean like Spanish Silva and
then he got tested tonight and really
respected wow so I've never moved up in
my book I mean and I respected him
beforehand I just thought that like damn
dude this is a really tough fight now
he's gonna fight Canelo next no no don't
be crazy well I mean yeah that's what
people say oh let's see I do against
Ryan Garcia or Canelo Jesus Christ why
why are we jumping there small yeah
right yeah yeah but Ryan Garcia's left
hook would put him no right here yeah
that's a stupid fight oh yeah oh my god
dude the timing too flat on his head
okay Anderson knew he got on his knee
because he was like I'm gonna fall over
if I don't take a second
he's like I mean you knocked down the
bigger guy late in the round that
power's still there boop boop
Boop
bang right on the bus right on the
button
that's impressive man is that a judge
right there the guy with the clipboard
the guy who had the Jake Paul tattoo
Boop and then just boom
that's insane at his level to knock down
someone on his ass like that you're nuts
look at all I don't know like dude that
was impressive yeah I agree absolutely
this damn this dude was fighting on the
undercard of [ __ ] Logan Paul KSI a
few years ago against another YouTuber
that and it was like right now I mean he
dedicated some stuff to do yeah I'll
tell you right now I guarantee you these
YouTubers like KSI and all that stuff
guarantees are not calling Jake Paul
[ __ ] no no like you like other YouTubers
they fight no they didn't murder them no
they're like oh we don't no I don't want
that no I don't want those problems no
and he's in a different category he went
eight rounds of Anderson Silva beat him
on points and knocked him down broke his
nose yeah I thought even without the
knockdowns if he won that round he would
get the decision yeah but I kind of came
down to that round for me me too he
knocked him down in the last round too
yeah
which I didn't think he'd be able to
yeah I thought his power would diminish
as he went just because if nerves are
young five fights the pace I was worried
about your pace Anderson's moving in on
him and grinding him and he hasn't seen
that before no he's never been put in a
war like that and he responded he was
curious what happens when you get into a
tough fight now we know yeah that dude's
a warrior yeah yeah has all the respect
for me that's your job is to sit there
and smile it's crazy bro it was like
it's a crazy gig hi
you guys have no clue how hard it is
yeah what is the point of them there
though I know that's what khabib says
yeah could be paid yeah no right
the round girls he's like they're not
gonna be round girls in Eagle FC they're
pointless and then someone's like how
about round dudes he's like absolutely
not yeah there he goes it's official
what was the uh I think you meant
unanimous decision
do we know the the scores right
I would assume
yeah
77 74 Jake so it's split
no no no okay no unanimous
wait 77.
before the fight I didn't call that
three rounds into the fight like that's
impressive yeah so they gave him they
gave Jake five rounds in Anderson three
yeah
you can go watch my prediction we post
on Instagram three minutes before the
card started I said Jake weak in a late
knockout did you really yep good job
buddy I thought I would still be there I
thought answering get up on him just
from his experience and then Jake I
thought Ashley would get a little more
take more chances and Jake would land
something that's the good thing about
these fight companions you're like
remember that prediction I made that's
on wax son yeah now last week I went two
for five but Steve it was tough yeah oh
look at those numbers dude power shots
body shots landed total 83 to 79 we
landed landed 51 pounds that's his dad
right there wait that's
so Anderson landed innocent landed more
power uh less Jabs
less total and the body shots you know
almost double
yeah Jake won that [ __ ] fight dance
oh yeah any way you look at when that
fight there's no there's no controversy
he's not even close I assume he calls
out Nate now that's fine it was a tough
close fight along hey but the decision
being what it was was completely hey
here's my thing now are you guys
rethinking about uh Jake versus Nate I
think Jake yeah I think Jake I do too
yeah yeah
now I wonder if he still wants to keep
doing this MMA thing it's smart you're
making great money yeah and also at the
level he needs to get out to face a box
that we would know you're fighting a
real real boxer yeah like if you're
trying to get up there and I don't know
who wants to fight you know the it's not
worth it there's no boxers that are big
names by the time he fights a guy with a
big name he's fighting a killer yeah
that's my whole point yeah well that's
why he was doing Tommy Fury rockman's
kid
I do Nate next then I do Connor like she
can get that Connor fight somehow
so what do you guys think about that oh
so how tall is G I can't pick against
Connor I think I should take my B Connor
man yeah
he has power conditioning his boxing and
stuff and also I mean he's a bigger guy
than comments
he's five nine two yeah
but Jake Paul that's what I'm saying
he's distinctively bigger now just to be
clear Anderson Silva Nate Diaz Conor
McGregor and Silva's the worst matchup
for Jake by far I think yeah
yeah no I agree with you and Anderson
box box yeah you know Conor MMA boxing
Nate Diaz does you know too small I
think I think he is too small but I mean
that being said that's why I think Jake
still beats him I mean now here's a
crazy question would Floyd Mayweather
ever get in with Jake Paul yeah that's
who I sat with him I talked to Caesar I
took the Caesar Gracie the day after
Nate beat Tony and I was like dude you
should get Nate start campaigning for
that [ __ ] Floyd Mayweather fight
because Floyd I'd rather watch Floyd
means dance Partners I'd rather watch
I'd rather watch Nate vs uh Floyd than
Connor Floyd again I'm all set on Connor
Floyd yeah I'm good yeah I mean today I
mean Nate and uh Floyd it's interesting
yeah
if I'm Jake I don't fight Floyd that's
it it's gonna be a boring fight it's not
good it'll look like the Logan Paul
would except yeah it'll be the same yeah
I mean Floyd makes everybody look bad
yeah I mean Diaz called him a [ __ ]
there you go that's the move that's the
money fight
now now they came and negotiated now
January 2020. he's there but he but he
can't negotiate contractually until next
year because because his Sunset classes
oh no no all right all right Jakey come
on I know you're hiding what are you
doing uh Canelo Alvarez that sounds good
but I mean that's oh dude that wouldn't
go that only go past two minutes that's
it but how big is Canelo
canelo's five six five six five seven
Max five seven I mean congratulations to
Ariel for getting this gig but if you're
gonna wear a suit like that you need to
get that tailored Doug oh is it not
Taylor that doesn't look there but but
also listen I'm drinking the J Kool-Aid
hard like you are Sam I'm not drinking
enough where I want to see him fighting
Sam's like I want to see him Terence
Crawford right now yeah
I want Tyson Fury Jake Paul
dog yeah it's a big difference wait
who's six one
but you gotta talking about a prime box
or world class wow
okay yeah that's not a 40. literally
yeah MMA guy who's also dabbling in
boxing I mean it's literally one of the
things he said ready eight what 82
fights something like that 62 fights I
mean dude no no there's only lost seals
what um Mayweather right and then he
lost that he lost a couple fights ago
when he was oh yeah he went way up and
he was and he was eating vegan I heard
too like no really or something like
that oh yeah that destroyed Cam Newton
remember when he got busted there's my
girl hi boo
remember when Canelo got busted I mean I
mean Canelo just beat Caleb plant for
God's sakes Caleb's a monster he broke
his he broke his [ __ ] orbital it's
nuts dude yeah but I don't want to talk
about it
oh yeah good for him
that's a class act now does Jake realize
well the money has like the way in
boxing you know you can CT right buddy
oh he's already said it yeah well I only
live once all right yeah yeah not here
for a long time we're here for a good
time all right be the man you want to be
is that right you're sober but whatever
but I might get how long how much longer
do you want to unbox you just start
Crossing off lists call it a day that's
my thing how much longer do you want to
do like if let's say if you beat Nate
right you beat Nate then maybe you're
counter fight but you can stick around
fight a low level boxer who's been doing
it maybe he's an Olympic boxer you know
that has two fights that we don't know
like just to prove what we're good man
for what you've done is impressive I
don't need you to fight some guy we've
never heard of that's maybe an Olympian
because that's what homeboy did uh over
in England what's his name the promoter
over there suing him Eddie Hearn because
uh Jake you think you're a real boxer I
have a box for you he's 2-0 and Jake
goes yeah I'll find him he was cool you
look the guy up he won a gold medal in
the Olympics boxing so he's one of those
Pros yeah yeah okay he's gonna [ __ ] them
up yeah it's a terrible idea it's like
in for what validation from the boxing
Community most of them are dinosaurs who
gives a [ __ ] yeah now what is the
lawsuit about because Jake said that
Eddie Hearn there's like some uh because
he had that that female fighter and
Katie Taylor he says they're paying the
judges off I felt this judge Feldman had
some questionable calls and crazy yeah
yeah and a few consecutive fights and
and he just directly was like he's
getting paid by matchbook where it's
just like there's ways to say it without
setting yourself up for a defamation
lawsuit he didn't do it well like he he
could have said much better yeah they've
seen him for a hundred million dollars
dude Chael did the funniest video like
is now Feldman tacked on to the lawsuit
and chilled to this video that was so
funny he's like hey bro how are you
being defamed no one knows who the [ __ ]
you are for Feldman yeah
boy that was a lot better fight than I
thought even though I called it I
thought he was gonna knock him out not a
decision but still that's amazing I was
a woman in glasses
uh that might be uh Logan's assistant
and she's good too because on the show
we brought up dunkaroos our favorite
snacks as kids
I mean she comes in 10 minutes later and
was like here's your dunkaroos
but actually when I say she did it my
Mike was there with me filming Mike went
and got the dunkaroos but it was her
idea she's adding value well Mike added
the value there with that yeah
but they changed the icing on Duck
grooves for your kids out there it's not
the same
I love that [ __ ] look at Logan dude
man what a Redemption what a Amazing
Story
look at this brother unbelievable who's
older Logan now now here's what's
interesting when I had Logan food truck
he goes you know how this is going to
work out right he's like we promised our
parents we never fight but this ends
with us fighting chosen biggest
pay-per-view of all time
he's like I'm gonna fight my brother
he's like because it makes the scores
that's brilliant I think Jake beats his
brother you know dude that was super
super random how they knew where to
water balloon Dylan Dennis
that was dude it's brilliant these guys
are brilliant at marketing dude yeah
they can also [ __ ] fight now Logan
not so much Logan you know he does his
thing whatever and against Floyd what it
is so super impressive to go the
decision even though he lost but you
know he did well for what Jake's they're
on different paths Logan's doing you
find the KSI is the YouTubers that's
whatever he's doing for fame and money
legit legitimately trying to yeah take
over the world yeah and he's he's taking
a tough like Angel still was not an easy
no honestly I thought it was a bad move
me too you know what I mean if I would
have been in the room and like Hey we're
gonna fight Anderson Silva I'm like can
we pick again yeah like really why you
know what I mean like okay you're gonna
beat him and maybe but I'm like yeah and
most likely you're not going to beat
them you know I mean the guys reach is
boxing is experience fighter with five
fight let's say it's your daughter yeah
they they gave her some Legends you go
what makes no sense I don't know no
Jake's just on a different path
I was like how does Jake Paul possibly
win a decision against Andrew still I
know that he did yeah I knocked him down
nuts I mean that's about as as of
decisive of Victory as you can he was
like well I didn't catch you didn't
knock you out like yeah I did knock you
down but I won on you know every round
but two you know George St Pierre's
highlights are on point bro yeah and I
love him it's Bob I like when he was a
shaved head on he probably does that for
the Hollywood [ __ ] uh dad's uh UFC
announced anything just I haven't paid
attention have they announced any big
fights recently not really uh not really
they announced that Jon Jones is like
not happening oh we talked about that a
lot but yeah but you see John he I think
yeah he's like hey Steve base sign the
[ __ ] contract December 10th let's go
what's going on here yeah so I I've
heard rumors that Stipe and I'm it's
it's either hunter or Sean like they
like have some kind of issue
I don't know which one it is but like it
doesn't sound like it's a John issue
yeah
I'd like to see John fight again of
course you know you can't go forever man
no I mean I mean I mean we've lost a lot
of years by his own his own choice to
get going though because two years off
then yeah this thing like let's go dude
yeah it's kind of and you know you're
like me I love Connor let's get going
dude yeah like I know you're not in the
drug pool you know you're not getting
but do you think he can get back to
where he was kind of I mean so much
money he can win fights though like if
they even write matchups he can still
win now is he beating Mach chip
absolutely not you know when he says uh
out of the style to beat him like oh
dude no no you don't no and if I'm his
team I'm going to listen we know what I
just saw from Macho like I don't know if
I'm in the lightweight division I'd be
moving up and moving down me too
you might be the one time you catch him
with a kick something happens I mean it
is MMA you doc throw an elbow that
rematch would be terrible for you yeah
you're not gonna catch him again you get
your [ __ ] yeah
you're beat up
focusing on the next the next
pay-per-view is what Anderson uh pierra
oh [ __ ] uh Alan uh uh Arnold Allen beat
cater I didn't like that fight for him
and how do you get it done Peter folded
his knee it's really [ __ ] up cater
went for a flying knee and he came down
and tore his MC like he he's you know
it wasn't a bike no it was an injury
that's a bummer I love cater but uh
Arnold two more years two more weeks he
felt like he he immediately when he came
down he fell they got to the end of the
round he came out he took one kick to
the leg and that was a wrap it was like
like he just come he was he was hurt
dude
but yeah right hall got it done yeah you
know what man what up here a guy's kind
of scary
I mean like
that means a lot of signings have to
stand up with them for five rounds and
not get touched
yeah but my only thing with that is like
people like everyone's all high on
period I get it Savage knocked them out
and kickboxing but if you go back and
watch that fight yeah
but again he was on roller skates yeah a
couple times yeah they both land good
shots and then you know I've seen the
final shot but I just think MMA is
different I think Izzy has more
experience at that high level
Pierre of his best win Strickland all
day outside that he really hasn't earned
the only reason he's fighting those kids
yeah
narrative outside that like pure would
never I mean there's no way and here's
the thing Pierre beats him they do the
rematch to say Pierre beats him again
who's Pierre gonna beat like if anybody
can if a blue belt would roll that guy
up he's gonna have his hands full yeah
because I think Victoria beats all day
vittori Paulo costumes uh Whitaker
hamzat would absolutely mop the floor
with him so it's kind of short side I
think of the UFC but they need a
narrative for Izzy yeah
it's only five really makes sense for
him yeah that's what they're doing and
then he's going to go up I think
eventually but it's a scary ass fight
for him oh yes matchup wise I just think
he beat them listen I don't think he
like just absolutely like walks through
him like Mach chip did Charles Oliver
but I think he beats him then I think
there's nothing left for him I think you
know I think he unless homs out were to
come to middleweight but then I I do
think he goes to 205 and now a guy like
Yuri
I'm still going on the fact that they're
all just holding the belt for Beau
Knuckles until he's 100 dude I can't
wait
it sucks once it gets a little more
experience I think he pulls up you do
all day yeah including Hamza yeah yeah
oh yeah I want that fight I think he
beat Tom's out right now right now I
think arasania might be too much for him
to pick on right now at this point in
his career at that level going from zero
to a title shot yeah dude I mean uh Izzy
had trouble keeping Robert Whittaker off
him like Robert Whittaker is able to
take it down like
and but Robin could potentially win that
no no no he cannot saying he couldn't
I'm saying I'm excited to make sure he's
undefeated yeah let's not do that fight
now but in two years 100 you know I mean
like I bet the house on it because if
you say right now I'm like oh it's
competitive I think everybody else is
not even competitive I just don't like
going from you know whatever they put
him on the prelims whatever to the main
it's a different animal yeah yeah even
it's a difference there's a lot of other
prelims to the main card when you're the
second co-main event it's a lot of
pressure but the the environment's
different you're fighting really late so
for a bow to go from you know Dana White
Contender series to headlining against
Izzy it's just not send him up for
Success how many hours of like
interviews and [ __ ] you think you do for
the main event like oh my God and here's
a good example so lomachenko right yeah
oh is that that you fought tonight yeah
so lomachenko was what 396 in like one
Jackie Irwin was like the 2008 gold
medalist and he came back and beat him
twice right and became like the 2012 or
whatever it was 8 and 12 Olympic gold
medalists right so you have one of the
most decorated Olympic amateurs of all
you know amateur Fighters so his first
fight right off the bat he wants to
fight that guy salido like in Texas in
his hometown right away right away like
because he had so much confidence he
loses a decision now I've heard people
tell me that you know the decision might
not be what people think but whatever it
is they got dirty right yeah it was like
a dirty fight and the referee didn't
really break it up and he should have
and it allowed the guy to get away with
some stuff and so he pulled off that
being said like there you have a guy who
everybody thought was going to walk
through everybody and so bid on too much
too soon like let me I want to be the
first guy on my very first pro fight to
fight for a title well I ended up coming
so like and it was a close competitive
fight had the fight happen and so like
in Vegas then he probably wins the fight
right but but but you can take you can
bite on too much and not set your back
the title his first fight in the UFC
nobody's gonna mop the floor with him
yeah you know it could happen but like
it's like well but if you just wait two
years get this guy Five
Point what's what's the rush like it's a
it's a marathon not a Sprint so when Bo
does get there he doesn't have an
experience it's you know let's say [ __ ]
happens maybe and I don't think this is
the case but let's say he doesn't show
up with the bright lights he knocks out
three times out of the UFC next he's
coaching wrestling construction dude all
his fights have been Apex too like he
hasn't uh
I asked him about that because on food
truck but remember he was like dude
since I was six I was wrestling in front
of thousands of people he's like I was
an outlier and he was like then also on
the world circuit he's like especially
when I was wrestling dexa and Russia
like thousands of people are coming he's
like so people tell me that how would he
do over there
when are you going to Dagestan and
Destroy them because I asked them I go
dude there's a stack stain coming he's
like yeah I know he goes the problem is
people don't realize he goes I wrestle
against those guys how'd you do this oh
I didn't just beat them I destroyed
because the only reason he's like I
destroyed them he goes I have all the
answers yeah it was just because
is that it guys
I think that's it Sam where are you
gonna be bud how did Loma Chico do
tonight just go to Sam tripoli.com find
me on YouTube YouTube Sam youtube.com
Sam Tripoli I'm putting dates together
going all over the place especially
social club with Brian Collins love him
callum's the best I love him and uh it's
a great show watch a grown man take else
I'll watch romantic non-stop else
um and then I'm in San Antonio next week
Santo Thursday Friday Saturday LOL uh
comedy club in San Antonio every weekend
coming up right now yeah your boy's
grinding it's it's peak season respect
gotta work that hour so Santos next week
um we will have tiger steak available in
person a bunch of it because it's Texas
and then Houston November 10th through
the 12th uh Houston Improv I hope doing
a special appearance at a Specs I think
it's on Friday or Saturday the big specs
in Houston come try the award-winning uh
sweet thick nectar which is Tiger thick
come say what's up take a picture
whatever you want to talk about I'm sure
fights whatever but then also at The
Improv in Houston we'll have a bunch of
tiger thick somebody sponsored by Tiger
thanks to a great time so San Antonio
Houston Europe I end November in
Milwaukee uh I think it's Milwaukee
improv and then December I close out
2022 with the Ohi thick tour Providence
Rhode Island Washington DC DC Improv get
your tickets at thickboy.com
Jesse on fire you're the best brother
thank you and I'll be at San Antonio on
Saturday yeah come come see Jesse man
yeah and next week man we're doing our
fights fight Freedom fight that's right
tequino is our main event you know
Augusta Mendes a great Brazilian guy
he's actually uh Sean O'Malley's Jiu
Jitsu coach oh nice where can they see
that yeah well we do it on that cloud
Hub still but it'll be our last time
doing it on that but if they want to
come out if you're in the Phoenix area
you come out watch that'd be cool and
you guys got some big boy announces
coming up I'm excited man ground belt
Park yep all right guys San Antonio see
you next week love you guys thanks for
tuning in we're out
he's